working at the SCP Foundation might just
be the most exciting job a person can
ask for and by exciting we mean that if
you work as an SCP field operative
researcher or mobile Task Force member
you're much more likely to die a
horrific death on the job than say a
plumber but at least you get the honor
of proudly saying that you're the first
line of defense between the normal world
and the terrifying domain of the
anomalous well unless you're one of the
I.T guys then your work life is likely
as tedious and uneventful as the
computer tech guy working on The Geek
Squad but nothing is ever normal when it
comes to the SCP Foundation or even the
person whose job is helping other staff
members reset their email passwords may
run into the supernatural welcome to the
strange and frightening world of pattern
screamers and specifically
scp-000
scp-000 was first discovered completely
on accident by technical researcher
David Rosen a man intrinsically
connected to the pattern screamers
lurking on the SCP Foundation computer
database technical researcher Rosen is
actually somewhat of a celebrity around
the foundation staff due to the fact
that he's so perfectly mediocre at what
he does his job as the glorified I.T guy
of the SCP Foundation was previously
held by the more qualified researcher
Patrick Gephart but Rosen was called in
to replace him after Gephart
mysteriously disappeared while on the
job since 2012 Rosen has been site 19's
user level tech support wizard but the
best thing that can really be said about
his job competency is that he's got a
hundred percent attendance record he
seems to live out of his office which is
described as the filthiest of the whole
Foundation every inch of the floor is
covered in Old broken computer parts and
the air is stale with dust and the twin
odors of sweat and lithium grease it's a
place so inhospitable that the
foundation nation is seriously
considered bottling the stench as a kind
of chemical deterrent while technical
director Rosen isn't good at his job per
se he isn't technically bad enough at it
to justify the time and resources it
would take to replace him but the worst
part about Rosen isn't his performance
it is truly rotten attitude he's
universally described by his colleagues
as being rude grumpy and combative with
patients that's far too short for
someone working in tech support and
while Rosen does have a real fear that
the ghost of researcher Gephardt is
stalking him he was about to have his
first actual brush with the supernatural
it all started when he began receiving
automated repair tickets for
scp-000 a file that had no reason to
exist as any longtime follower of the
SCP Foundation will know the universal
designation for the first cluster of
scps to be discovered is
scp-001 there is no scp-000 0.00 it
simply doesn't exist and when Rosen
first found the file lurking on the
database he found that it was filled
with worthless nonsense the object class
was recorded as null the special
containment procedures read error field
containment underscore procedures does
not exist and the mess of a description
simply read internal System error field
undefined please contact system
administrator over and over again
becoming more mangled and nonsensical
each time technical director Rosen who
could never resist an opportunity to
complain decided to leave an angry
administrator's note on the useless file
he claimed that this pile of junk data
was sending out pointless repair tickets
because of its broken syntax clogging up
the system and preventing him from doing
actual work on meaningful files he
assumed that this was all down to the
database not knowing how to react to
having files logged with insufficient
information and he suppressed all future
repair tickets from scp-000 before for
declaring the matter over and done with
with the pig-headed technical director
didn't realize was that he was
suppressing a call for help from an
entity trapped in the white space below
the article itself it was a being born
into a pure white world of absolute
nothingness an entity with no name and
no place but it was somehow capable of
thought its panicked inner monologue is
readable in the hidden text which takes
the form of a rambling stream of
Consciousness the being first described
coming to life in this empty world with
no memories of where it was or even how
it got there it spent what could have
been years exploring the empty Wasteland
occasionally it would see horrific
monsters pop up around it but only for a
split second The Entity continued to
wander and little by little the
existential dread mounted as it realized
that it may truly be stuck here in
Oblivion Forever The Entity only had one
word to go on a word repeated by some of
the monsters it encountered Foundation
The Entity had no idea what this
Foundation even was but it grew to hate
and fearing was this Foundation the one
that trapped it here the entity had all
the Time in the World to speculate on it
eventually The Entity found its voice
like any sentient creature in trouble it
began to call for help eventually
screaming just hoping someone would
notice it these pleas likely translated
into the frequent it repair tickets a
coded SOS an attempt to show that
everything was not as it appeared on the
scp-000 file perhaps The Entity may have
found help if researcher Gephart was
still working at the foundation but
instead its cries fell on the ignorant
ears of technical director Rosen it may
as well have been speaking to a brick
wall Rosen who had all the investigative
Zeal of Paul Blart Mall Cop made sure
that these cries would never lead to the
entity's freedom when he suppressed the
repair tickets he had trapped the entity
in a private blank hell forever hating a
life it didn't choose and could never
escape a Relentless existential
nightmare this is the gist of your
average pattern screamer pattern
screamers are a perfect example of
literally making something out of
nothing they are often a kind of
floating Consciousness created from
nothing dropped in pockets of
nothingness between the fabric of
reality driven mad by the purgatory-like
nature of their existence their less
living entities and more conceptual
constructs pure ideas that just happen
to be self-aware of their own existence
in their private hellish voids the
scp-00 file a file for an anomaly that
doesn't exist and thus had no reason to
exist is a perfect breeding ground for a
pattern screamer but sadly for the
pattern screamer in question technical
director Rosen had no idea this isn't
the only time that Rosen had run into a
pattern screamer without even knowing
either and just like the first case he
was with no help whatsoever this one
began with scps an otherwise empty file
containing only this image director
Winters a foundation administrator
wondered why this file even existed
enter technical director Rosen filled
with equal parts sarcasm and
insubordination he gave a condescending
reply to director Winters saying that
the file was there to test the filing
system and the image was likely just a
placeholder Winters never should have
been on the page anyway according to
Rosen director Winters was annoyed at
rosen's typically rude tone and asked
him to make the purpose of the article
clearer in the article itself in
response Rosen did as he was told
filling the article in the most
sarcastic manner possible the whole
thing was essentially a middle finger to
director Winters for having the audacity
to even ask Rosen signed off with there
finished I certainly hope I have been
clear enough to anyone who may have
accidentally accessed this page so
through what I am sure is no fault of
their own so we won't have any more
incredibly competent directors bugging
the tech team about this page and once
again technical researcher Rose and was
too busy being a rude unpleasant jerk to
notice he was practically staring
another pattern screamer in the face
this pattern screamer or rather Hive of
pattern screamers were trapped even
deeper than the one in scp-000 this one
was hidden in the very source code of
scps where a chorus of enraged voices
screamed the following pretend monster
just for a minute pretend you were the
size of an amoeba dwarfed by even the
smallest of bugs pretend you didn't hold
the world in a glass cage pretend you
were the one being held by something
greater than yourself would you still be
laughing at your triumphs would you
still feel pride in what you were even
as pitifully small as you would be of
course you would because you are
arrogant and stupid if you haven't
guessed yet we hate you this pattern
screamer is clearly more aware of its
pitiful station in existence than the
zero zero zero pattern screamer and as a
result it's not so much depressed as it
is furious though at this point you've
probably figured out that even the
entities who have the most casual
brushes with technical researcher Rose
and end up getting infuriated but while
you may have gotten the impression that
all pattern screamers are sad little
entities worthy of our sympathy and pity
there's at least one pattern screamer
that's actually incredibly dangerous
this is
scp-3930 the ultimate pattern screamer
in terms of both size and effect it's an
anomaly so strange it defies typical
containment classification and it Bears
a level 5 security lock meaning only
those on the level of the legendary o5
Council are cleared to even know about
it its greatest containment procedure is
the preservation of the very idea that
scp-3930 does not exist because the
alternative has terrifying implications
for all involved
scp-3930 is a one kilometer area in
Russia that is filled with non-existence
to even call it a white void would be
inaccurate because it implies the
existence of the color white and the
existence of the concept of a void
nothing exists with an scp-3930 and
anyone who directly observes 3930 runs
the risk of actively increasing its
power that's why special containment
procedures dictate that anyone who
observes 3930 must be forced to walk
into it afterwards which results in them
ceasing to exist they're destroyed on
the deepest level that anything can be
destroyed the very idea of them ceases
to be another reason that scp-3930 is so
special is that because it's the largest
area of nothing in existence interacting
directly with our real quality it's the
only place that a huge number of
patterned screamers can be directly
observed by humans they're described as
being like sentient hallucinations one
researcher suggests that these pattern
screamers are created by the way the
psyche shatters when brought into
contact with raw true nothingness the
nothingness acts like a hateful mirror
to our worst thoughts reflecting them
back at us in the forms of restless
screamers regardless of what they
actually are one thing is for sure
coming into direct contact with one of
these screamers is a harrowing
experience in the end it just goes to
show that pattern screamers are a
complex entity they can range from
microscopic to massive from pitiful to
downright terrifying and the sad result
is that in either case nothing can
really be done to stop them it's just as
impossible to stop the nothingness
existing in scp-3930 as it is to save
the entity trapped in the white spaces
of scp-000 0.00 maybe the best option is
to actually be more like technical
director Rosen keep your head down Focus
instead on your own Petty worries and
bask in the warm Bliss that can only
come with having no idea what you're
dealing with the one downside is that
this may make you a pretty lousy it guy
there are some things human beings
aren't meant to know and it's the sworn
duty of the SCP Foundation to discover
and contain such information but
sometimes knowledge is discovered that
shakes even the foundation itself to its
very core one such Discovery occurred on
April 28 2016. that night
scp-2935 made itself known to the
foundation Personnel to this day the
exact nature of scp-2935 is a mystery
that even the foundation's brightest
Minds can't completely understand
everything we know about
scp-2935 today comes from three doomed
missions to the anomalous Zone's
interior this is the story of those
Infamous Expeditions the nightmare here
began around 5am when SCP Foundation
site 81 in Bloomingdale Indiana
intercepted the distorted radio signal
Communications Personnel at the site
traced this strange signal back to the
unincorporated area of Joppa Indiana
near U.S Interstate 70. as is foundation
policy a team of field agents were
dispatched to the location in order to
determine what they were dealing with
however rather than finding anything
that could logically produce such a
signal they instead discovered a long
abandoned Cemetery the most recent death
on any of the Tombstones was recorded as
being over a hundred years ago all the
way back in 1908 on further
investigation the foundation discovered
an unmapped Limestone Cave opening
beneath the cemetery and when they sent
a drone into the depths of the cave it
appeared to quickly exit out the other
side of the cave but something wasn't
right the area that the Drone was
observing appeared consistent with the
landscape from which it entered but now
it looked somehow grayer it lacked the
color of life of the place it just come
from the grass was dead there were no
trees no shrubs no animals or birds in
the sky they weren't looking at our
world they were looking at a strange
reflection of our world on the other
side of the cave in fact it wasn't a
cave at all it was a passageway between
two Dimensions it was
scp-2935 just then they were able to
unscramble the distorted transmission
they'd been receiving it went as follows
this is an automated emergency broadcast
from the SCP Foundation and
international government one or more of
our sites is experiencing a
communication breakdown likely due to a
containment breach of unknown magnitude
all citizens are ordered to stay in
their homes as containment teams worked
to secure the breach this message will
broadcast from April 20th 2016. until at
that point the message would cut and
repeat as it had for eight straight days
the message Source site 81 but not this
site-81 the SCP Foundation was receiving
an emergency distress signal from
themselves in another dimension a
bizarre event that even the foundation
had never experienced before Field age
agents were terrified by the
implications of what they just heard and
contacted site 81 commands to request
additional units the foundation wished
to fully understand this anomaly as
quickly as possible due to the Potential
Threat it could pose toward the
foundation so they dispatched mobile
task force Epsilon 13 codenamed Manifest
Destiny to perform the first of three
manned missions Into the Heart of the
anomalous Zone the first exploratory
Mission into scp-2935 was codenamed
Gauntlet and consisted of a four-man
team fitted with full hazmat suits and
direct video and audio links to Mission
command the team was led by a field
operative known only as agent Juno his
subordinates were agents kale Devon and
Underwood their directive was to gather
samples and Survey the area positioned
directly around the insertion point
meaning the other cave mouth of scp-2935
the mission only lasted about an hour
but what they saw in there would stay
with these men for the rest of their
lives after a 15-minute Trek through the
cave Manifest Destiny arrived in the
mirror Dimension where they were struck
by the Erie every Silence of a place
that seemed identical and yet so
different from their home Dimension the
first observation they made was the
total absence of all living vegetation
trees grass weeds everything it was all
dead on orders from their superiors back
in the original Dimension that we'll
refer to from here on as Dimension Prime
Manifest Destiny headed deeper into the
mirror dimension of scp-2935 they travel
two kilometers without detecting a
single sign of plant or animal life not
even insects eventually They Came Upon a
farmhouse with two cars parked outside
with authorization from command Manifest
Destiny breached the house and headed
inside agent kale confirmed that there
was still power flowing to the building
as the lighting appeared to work just
fine but They Came Upon A horrifying
Discovery in The house's dining room
three adult corpses two female one male
were seated at the table a fourth corpse
that of a male child was sprawled out on
the ground nearby as if the death of
what looked to be an entire family
wasn't awful enough the Manifest Destiny
team noticed a number of other alarming
details there were no signs of
decomposition on the bodies nor did
there appear to be any obvious cause of
death the Family's last meal was still
on the table chicken mashed potatoes and
green beans while the food looked cold
and stale there was no evidence of rot
or spoiling the team found an open
newspaper dated April 19 2016
illustrating that the family may have
died a full eight days before the
discovery in dimension Prime Decay would
already be very well underway by that
point yet here there wasn't even a smell
instead everything was just covered in a
thin layer of dust command requested
that Manifest Destiny collects samples
of the food as well as Hair Skin and
fluids from the corpses for further
study small electronics like smartphones
were also taken from the bodies agent
Devin turned on the television in the
living room and found that while most
stations were now running test signals
the shopping channel was still live well
the feed was live at least both hosts
sat in front of the cameras dead but
perfectly preserved the date on the
screen read April 28 2016 suggesting
that the times of Dimension Prime and
mirror Dimension were exactly the same
name in fact everything seemed the same
the only difference between the two
Dimensions being that some kind of
mysterious apocalyptic event had
occurred in the last eight days in
scp-2935's Mirror Dimension but exactly
what had happened or how remained a
mystery when Manifest Destiny exited the
Farmhouse they once again remarked on
the lack of all signs of life around
them at this point the team returned to
the insertion point of scp-2935 but were
instructed to remain in the mirror
Dimension while additional units joined
them inside Manifest Destiny swelled the
16 members with the notable edition of
agent Roy as the new commanding field
officer the team split into two groups
of eight and agent Roy and his men
infiltrated the mirror Dimension site-81
while agent Juno's Detachment attempted
to access the basis off-site deep
storage servers this second expedition
was codenamed Overland and led the
foundation's field agents even deeper
into the terrifying mystery of scp-2935
accessing the site was easy for Roy's
Detachment it seems there were
relatively few cars on the road at the
time of the mysterious Extinction event
in the distance fires still smoldered in
the wreckage of planes that looked to
have just dropped out of the sky agent
Roy and his team like all SCP Foundation
Personnel were fitted with vitals
trackers and they assumed that the
distress signal that started this whole
thing could have been triggered by the
deaths of every member of the foundation
at Once In The Mirror Universe once
inside site 81 they realized that the
Assumption was probably right going door
to door in the administrative Wing they
found the perfectly preserved corpses of
everyone they knew to be stationed there
in dimension Prime people who were
without a doubt still alive in their
Universe samples from the corpses that
the foundation would later study even
confirmed the reason that the bodies
were perfectly preserved the corpses had
experienced complete and sudden death on
a cellular level and even the bacteria
that would typically take part in the
decomposition process had died with it
an scp-2935 death was total and absolute
across all types of life forms as agent
Roy's team ventured further into the
bowels of site-81 they made another
settling Discovery their own corpses in
roughly the same spots they'd been
inside Dimension Prime site 81 eight
days prior some of the foundation's top
scientists including the esteemed Dr
bright were also found dead inside the
facility in an attempt to see just how
far this unexplained phenomenon
stretched agent Roy's team decided to
inspect the containment cells where they
found that all the mirror universes scps
including
scp-2996 were dead in his desperation to
find some kind of exception to the
extinction event agent Roy revealed a
terrifying secret to the rest of his
team scp-682 The Immortal misanthropic
lizard and one of the deadliest
creatures known to the SCP Foundation
was contained at this very facility
right below them could it have something
to do with what was going on here they
descended into the containment facility
to discover an even more unsettling
truth scp-682 the unkillable anomaly
floated dead in its tank death truly
made no exceptions within scp-2935 agent
Roy's team left the site in Grande food
with agent Juno's team to send their
research back to Dimension prime using
automated drones both teams remained in
the mirror dimension for another manned
operation codenamed 19. they had no idea
it would be their final mission as they
descended deeper into the facility
passing more dead scps they discovered
one final clue based on the activity of
the foundation servers the event
occurred at roughly 3 A.M while
underground in scp-2935 site-81 the team
accidentally activated the bases on-site
nuclear weapon a Fail-Safe meant to be
detonated in the case of an emergency
Containment Breach due to the base's
Fail-Safe protocols every member of the
Manifest Destiny team was locked and
sealed inside site-81 they along with
everything else were incinerated in the
nuclear blast once again the Mirror
Universe inside of scp-2935 was lifeless
but that isn't where it ends when the
automated drones returned out of the
scp-2935 cave to the field operations in
dimension Prime they were in for their
own horrifying discussion recovery none
of the footage or information gathered
from scp-2935 illuminated how or why the
extinction event occurred everyone and
everything simply dropped dead at the
exact same moment nobody was aware
nobody was prepared death came suddenly
and silently and none were spared all
the foundation on Dimension Prime were
left with was a message from one of the
agents from Manifest Destiny agent
Keller his final message was I don't
have any answers I don't think there are
any I'll do this one thing and hope that
fixes it seal it shut you've got to lock
it in here with us I'm sorry the
foundation were at first confused by
this until they discovered a final
encrypted audio log buried in the files
recovered from the mirror universe's
site 81 it was a message from Keller
himself but not the Keller from Universe
Prime in this message Keller described
the foundation in the Mirror Universe
receiving the exact same distorted
transmission that they did a few days
earlier from a cave in Joppa when he and
the others were dispatched inside they
discovered the same lifeless
post-extinction event world that was now
so familiar failure to the foundation
command but there was a key difference
this wasn't the mirror Dimension they'd
just been studying but a third entirely
different dimension in his haunting
final words mirror Dimension Keller
admits that whatever caused the event in
that third dimension an entity in that
mirror Dimension Keller believes this
was the Specter of death itself and had
followed him back into his world and
history had repeated itself
scp-2935 was the passageway through
which absolute death could pass from
Dimension to Dimension and our Dimension
was the next in line the deaths of
manifest destiny may have saved our
entire universe as anyone passing back
through the cave had the potential to
bring death itself back with them the
foundation decided in the end to follow
Keller's advice they sealed the entrance
to scp-2935 with concrete and now kept
it under constant watch since what Waits
behind the barrier is an entity even
they have no power to stop if it ever
got through after all it had killed them
all before or at least another version
of them what's one more dimension on the
pile why it may now just seem like a
simple slab of concrete under an
abandoned Cemetery this is why scp-2935
might be the most dangerous SCP of all
an SCP Foundation researcher sits at a
table inside of a standard containment
cell these are often dangerous places to
be especially when the SCP you're
supposed to be studying is one that you
can't see the researcher is taking notes
unsure of exactly what is going to
happen next he can hear the sounds of
knives scraping behind of Flesh sizzling
and Searing from high heat he braces
himself as a burst of heat hits the back
of his head as if a fireball has erupted
an object floats through the air and
settles in front of him on the table
it's a plate of food and it looks
delicious it may surprise you to learn
that there is no rule that the SCP
Foundation must deal exclusively with
violent and vicious creatures not every
SCP held in containment shares the same
malevolence in contempt for Humanity as
scp-682
for the world ending threat posed by the
likes of
scp-2317 some perhaps not many but some
are benign and might even seem outwardly
friendly but you'd still be taking a
huge risk to assume that anything
contained by the SCP Foundation is
completely harmless such is the case
with
scp-5031 as per the foundation's
containment procedures this
quasi-humanoid meaning it appears to
have some vaguely human features is held
in an airtight cell that is regularly
checked by Foundation Personnel on a
bi-weekly basis
scp-5031 has no need for regular
nutrition or regular interactions from
staff the trick with scp-5031 is not
being eaten by it since though it
doesn't need food it does still hunt and
consume anything it encounters human or
otherwise
avoiding being eaten is hard enough with
creatures that can actually be seen But
like so many other creatures the
foundation keeps contained
scp-5031 has developed an almost perfect
defense mechanism which is when observed
it will literally cease to exist
some might choose to refer to this as a
Quantum lock however it is worth noting
that Trace is left by scp-5031 still
remain observable when the creature has
temporarily disappeared for example
Trails of blood and scratch marks left
behind by scp-5031s still exist when the
SCP itself does not
naturally this makes both avoiding the
creature and capturing it using cameras
difficult however when scp-5031's
existence ceases it still casts a shadow
from this researchers have been able to
determine several of the creature's
physical traits
based on its silhouette it has been
deduced at scp-5031 levitates about half
a meter above ground level Sports in
abnormally small necklace head atop an
elongated torso approximately 1.9 meters
long with three sets of spindly lower
arms that Branch outwards using these
arms and its Loosely hanging body
scp-5031 will lower itself to hunt any
human or animal that draws near to it
and uses the blade-like tail to cut up
food
perhaps the most interesting facet of
scp-5031 Beyond its defensive
capabilities and apparent physical
attributes for the series of nine tests
conducted by senior researchers Stanley
Huxtable appalled by the conditions that
the creature was being kept in Huxtable
took over the role of HCL supervisor for
scp-5031 having grown increasingly
frustrated and empathetic towards the
creature listening to its screams from
inside its iron containment unit
Huxtable devised a series of tests to
introduce scp-5031 to various different
stimuli as a way to better understand
the creature and hopefully keep it
contained in a way that didn't seem to
cause so much suffering it's worth
remembering that the SCP Foundation
makes its mission to be cold not cruel
in performing their duties to protect
normality
and many of the researchers and staff
are just as capable of having empathy
for creatures as you might for a stray
animal at a shelter
the first of huxtable's tests involved
installing speakers in scp-5031 cell
through which a variety of different
ambient and popular pieces of music were
played to see if they had any effect on
reducing the creature's stress by
judging scp-5031 stress levels based on
how much it screamed when compared to
normal
Huxtable was able to determine how to
best use music to calm the creature
scp-5031 seemed to convey higher levels
of stress when listening to morning
Forest deep Grotto and seaside Paradise
Ambience as well as the best of late 60s
British rock band Jethro Tull however
the best of Mozart Enya kiss and Ben
Folds produce dramatically different
results decreasing scp-5031's apparent
stress following this test senior
researcher Huxtable compiled a playlist
featuring
scp-5031's favorite music over time the
stress reducing effects of Music on
scp-5031 seem to decrease
keeping the playlist on shuffle seemed
to keep the creature consistently calmer
than it had been previously
the next test involved introducing
inanimate objects into
scp-5031's enclosure to monitor its
reactions and how its stress levels were
affected when a softball was thrown into
the enclosure
scp-5031 immediately sliced the ball in
two with its tail in one swift motion a
similar result occurred when researchers
threw the creature of basketball which
was quickly punctured and sliced open by
scp-5031's tail its stress levels first
seemed to diminish when the creature was
offered a bowling ball which it rolled
around the enclosure and then later
knocked it against a second volleyball
however when one of the balls chipped
rendering it unable to roll properly
scp-5031 stress increased dramatically
until a replacement was offered
researcher Huxtable noted that scp-5031
seemed to possess a similar level of
motor skills to an average human toddler
with similarly explosive emotional
reactions to match
next when given the choice between two
food sources at opposite ends of its
enclosure
scp-5031 seemed to gravitate towards
higher quality food most notably favored
cooked rotisserie chickens over animal
carcasses
it even chose this option over a live
chicken using its tail to cut its food
into more manageable bite-sized portions
rather than ripping its meat with its
hands or teeth like many of its fellow
scps
researcher Huxtable recorded these
findings and highlighted that even
though scp-5031 didn't need to eat in
order to survive
providing the creature with food of a
better quality marginally reduced its
stress
senior researcher Huxtable next
attempted to test
scp-5031's coexistence with other living
subjects
each time making sure that the creature
had been adequately fed to avoid any
unseemly incidents
first a live chicken was introduced
scp-5031 rolled its bowling ball at high
speed towards the chicken increasing
both its and the chicken stress levels
and inadvertently killing the chicken in
the process
when a second chicken was introduced
scp-5031 gently rolled a basketball
towards it but ceased any further
engagement after the chicken squawked
from being hit by the ball next to be
introduced into the enclosure was a
blindfolded d-class staff member who was
instructed to sit down and roll the
basketball towards scp-5031 after doing
so for several minutes the creature
began to approach the d-class subject
who was instructed to remove their
blindfold to Cease the creature's
existence and prevent any potentially
deadly incidents finally researcher
Huxtable had another class D engage in a
game of catch with scp-5031 while facing
away from the creature
this test proceeded successfully and
Senior researcher Huxtable remarked how
scp-5031's motor skills were improving
albeit gradually and with some gentle
encouragement through huxtable's tests
the creature was learning
the next test focused on teaching
scp-5031 linguistic symbols utilized LCD
displays and buttons connected to a food
dispenser One display showed an image of
a rock and the other an image of a
rotisserie chicken after some brief
probing
scp-5031 was quickly able to understand
that pressing the button under the
correct display would dispense a
rotisserie chicken for it to eat the
creature was later able to adapt when
the following day the screen displays
and materials dispensed were swapped and
then later set to swap at random
intervals when additional Rock
dispensing stations were introduced this
time displaying the word rock as opposed
to an image
scp-5031 was able to determine which
station dispensed chicken through a
process of elimination whenever the
functions and displays were swapped
scp-5031 would find whichever displayed
the word chicken to receive its food the
Final Phase of this test presented
scp-5031 with a single station
displaying the word chicken but with a
button that would remain in active
unless the creature spelled out the same
word with a collection of lettered
blocks it was provided with after some
initial confusion and frustrations as to
why the button would not dispense food
when pressed
scp-5031 was able to assemble the word
correctly not only activating the button
and dispensing food but proving to
researcher Huxtable that the creature
was capable of learning language
Huxtable continued to test the creature
encouraging it to spell words using
lettered blocks as a method of
communicating by increasing scp-5031's
vocabulary and the amount of human
interaction it received senior
researcher Huxtable observed that
scp-5031 was gradually learning to sing
albeit non-verbally as well as to juggle
with its six hands and was even
communicating its food preferences and
Dish pairings
later another class D
d52125 was introduced to scp-5031's
enclosure to Aid and further testing
through
d-52125's instructions the creature
quickly learned to draw using crayons
and created artworks depicting itself
its Newfound friend
d-52125 researcher Huxtable a cat and a
rotisserie chicken
scp-5031's new creative side didn't stop
there though as the creature quickly
learned to play chopsticks in only two
days once a piano was introduced into
the enclosure
scp-5031 even managed to start creating
its own original admittedly crude
compositions next a spice rack was
placed inside the creature's cell and
d-52125 demonstrated how to season meat
this proved to be
scp-5031's new favorite hobby as it
spent the next three days experimenting
with different combinations of foods and
spices using its letter blocks to
request more more garlic powder
interestingly the creature only created
artwork or music when d-52125 was
present but seemed to thoroughly enjoy
its experimentation with food when left
alone
following this development senior
researcher Huxtable devised a new test
for scp-5031 providing the creature with
cooking utensils and using
d-52125 to demonstrate 5031 was shown
how to prepare a variety of different
dishes from hamburgers and Tacos to
Mongolian beef steak clam chowder and
profiteroles in addition to a small
peanut allergy this eighth test revealed
scp-5031 to be a phenomenal chef
possessing culinary skills far beyond
the average person the creature quickly
and enthusiastically embraced its
Newfound talents concocting its very own
brand new recipes with
d-52125 even volunteering to be the
first to taste test 50 31's dishes it
was shortly after this test that
scp-5031 spoke its very first word
and it should come as no surprise that
the word was solved naturally senior
researcher Huxtable was very proud of
the progress the creature had made with
its development the final test almost
seemed to be what the creature was born
for over the course of two months
scp-5031 was tasked with creating a full
three-course meal which would then be
served to Foundation staff for
Thanksgiving
scp-5031 not only Rose to the task but
exceeded all of researcher huxtable's
expectations creating a meal that even
Gordon Ramsay would be hard-pressed to
find fault with
the creature created a first course
consisting of sweet potato miso soup
seasoned with turmeric next came a
beautiful duck confi glazed luxuriously
with apple cider and topped generously
with sweet cranberry compote paired with
a side of butternut squash gnocchi and
served on a bed of kale seasoned with
truffle salt the grand finale of the
Exquisite meal was a spice cassava pie
for dessert complimented with the finest
French vanilla ice cream and a maple
hazelnut syrup
an scp-5031 didn't stop there the
creature also debuted one of its
original musical compositions to
complement the decadent meal it had
created as the staff enjoyed the food
scp-5031 performed live from its
enclosure the deeply moving piano
concerto for six hands to an
overwhelmingly positive response from
not only senior researcher Huxtable but
the entire Foundation staff as a fitting
end to the creature's tail Huxtable
reported that during the Thanksgiving
banquet it had created
scp-5031's stress levels reduced
entirely
new Kinder containment measures that
would keep 5031 safer but also far more
contented were submitted for approval
perhaps some of you may find it
refreshing to learn that scp-5031 isn't
simply just another malicious malevolent
monster that the foundation has to keep
under lock and key for the safety of the
world
instead
scp-5031 is a gentle if a little
frightening at first creature that just
requires careful and considered guidance
instead of a cold iron cage an
around-the-clock arm guards through
testing senior researcher Stanley
Huxtable and his fellow Foundation staff
were not only able to help the creature
develop but also found what makes it
tick and not just for the purposes of
containing it instead it is hoped that
scp-5031's creativity and Flair for
culinary and musical masterpieces can
continue to thrive and grow under the
proud watch of researcher Huxtable over
50 men and women clad in red robes kneel
before an Unholy altar they chant and
mutter indecipherable words words of
Cruelty and Madness of obsession and
sacrilege not long ago these were
regular people computer technicians
teachers plumbers construction workers
account
this was before they fell under the
ungodly influence of a new ruler the
center of this makeshift place of
worship was once a normal school
gymnasium but it's now the home of a
huge statue a humanoid being wreathed in
tentacles its head is more like a squid
or cuttlefish than anything resembling
an actual human face
while he's known to the cultists as the
tentacled god the Beast they worship is
known to the SCP Foundation as
scp-2662 and he sits in the belly of one
of their expansive containment
facilities locked away from the world
but not for long if his devoted
followers have anything to say about it
this is their God all-powerful and
unchanging and when it comes to
springing him from containment no tactic
is too vile or underhanded to get the
job done their mortal leader and high
priest a man in a purple robe calling
himself brother Marsh walks among their
crouched forms he whispers instructions
for the great day of Liberation that's
soon to come providing everyone plays
their part it's a plan months in the
making and one that if it goes off
without a hitch could free their
monstrous God into the world they would
strike at the very heart of their enemy
the SCP Foundation when they least
expect it and nothing shall stand in
their way how could they lose when they
have a God on their side but why did all
these normal people become violent
zealots for a squid-faced deity it all
began with a dream to those who
experience these dreams they felt more
like prophecies premonitions of the
Glorious Horrors to come a red sky
billions dead and billions more enslaved
a dark silhouette on the horizon their
tentacled God hold building Dominion
overall at first it just seemed like a
strange nightmare the ones who
experienced it woke up shaken in afraid
hoping to shake the images from their
mind but they couldn't every night the
nightmare would return they'd see the
images the Red Sky the dead and Enslaved
the tentacled God and after a while it
would come to them even when they
weren't asleep eventually happening
whenever they closed their eyes little
by little this scene stopped looking so
hideous and started to look glorious
they felt his presence in their minds
slowly pushing them towards their
inevitable future they started to
realize that they wanted him to rule
over the universe and to experience the
honor of serving him many of them
abandoned their homes and families
leaving their friends and loved ones
left to worry that they'd Gone Insane In
Their Eyes they were safer than they'd
ever been they finally had purpose they
were working in service of something far
greater than themselves the influence of
the tentacled god drew them closer to
one another
they would meet in secret exchanging
information from the prophecies their
rulers sent to them in their dreams they
worshiped together building altars and
Idols to congregate around they
performed dark blood rituals involving
human and animal sacrifice it was when
brother Marsh the anointed one arrived
to guide them towards their true mission
that things kicked into high gear just
three months prior brother Marsh had
been an office drone working in data
entry for a large insurance company
before the tentacled god invaded His
Thoughts with a simple message free me
and the new world I create shall be your
playground since then he devoted himself
completely to the cause quitting his job
and maxing out his credit cards to help
fund his new life's purpose infiltrating
the SCP Foundation and releasing his
inhuman ruler from its imprisonment that
was the single goal he United the
cultist under freedom for the tentacled
God and at long last they had all the
pieces in place to strike they'd finally
gathered the necessary Intel to subvert
the will of the most powerful secret
organization on Earth even the strongest
institution is made of people and people
are weak unlike the almighty tentacled
God people could be broken the people in
question were Kelly Thompson Sydney
Levitt Jordan brosh Dr Juan Gutierrez
and Jillian Larson Dr Juan Gutierrez was
a researcher with level 3 clearance on
the site where the tentacled God was
being contained Sydney Levitt and Jordan
brosh were both security officers
charged with verifying Personnel
clearance on site Kelly Thompson was a
member of site Administration with
research authorization powers and
Jillian Larson was a research assistant
who often collaborated with Dr Gutierrez
these five were the key to getting
access to
scp-2662 and bringing their plan
to fruition normally Personnel dossiers
on people working for the foundation
were highly confidential but the
devotees of the tentacled God had their
ways they had a number of computer
experts in their ranks more than capable
of hacking in and pulling some basic
information off of foundation servers
without being detected for the other
information they needed they turned to
some good old-fashioned torture which is
often the most effective method when you
need some quick results of course while
the Colts grip on sanity may have been a
little tenuous they weren't stupid while
Gathering their Intel they also made
sure to find out what exactly they were
up against
scp-2662 was being held in a humanoid
containment cell and guarded by on-site
Task Force Town nine better known as the
belligerent bodyguards these aren't lazy
donut chomping Mall Cops these are a
heavily trained heavily armed fighting
force though the cultists had one thing
that these Foundation soldiers didn't
the element of surprise for everything
to go off perfectly brother Marsh's
plans would have to be executed within a
single day and they were already on the
clock Tau 9 had been charged with
tracking down any new
scp-2662 Cults and dismantling them and
brother Marsh knew that it was only a
matter of time before the foundation
tracked them down and did the same to
them if they wanted any chance of
freeing the tentacled God then they'd
need to strike quickly and with
overwhelming Force the scp-2662
worshipers were able to secure the
addresses of the five key Foundation
personnel and station members outside
each of them including one who could
realistically imitate each they waited
for night to fall and broke into each of
their homes as they slept what followed
was a sequence of Ruthless and efficient
murders done in the cause of freeing
their God Dr Gutierrez was shot in the
head while he slept Sydney Levitt and
Jordan brosh were both stabbed to death
before either even realized what was
happening Thompson who'd gotten up to
use the bathroom went down in the hail
of machine gun fire Jillian Larson had
seen that mask Figures were breaking
into her home and attempted to flee but
was caught and beaten to death by
cultists in her hallway it was a strange
irony that people whose day jobs
entailed working with some of the most
dangerous and nightmarish anomalies
imaginable were murdered in their homes
by nothing more than regular humans
so far brother Marsh's plan had gone
perfectly with all five key personnel
murdered within a two-minute period next
the selected doppelgangers stole clothes
from their victims closets and were
handed the correct Forge documentation
the next morning each replacement began
their Journeys to the site where the
tentacled God was being contained while
the rest of the cult armed themselves in
preparation for their own part in the
plan
nobody at the foundation seemed to
notice anything amiss when the five
arrived on site when you work for the
SCP Foundation more mental energy is
devoted to following the rules that keep
you alive then two memorizing the faces
of all your co-workers and each one
slipped neatly into position
disappearing into the familiarity of
office life but infiltrating the site
was one thing getting past the
belligerent bodyguards and into the cell
of the tentacled God would be another
thing entirely that's where the rest of
the cult would come into play heavily
armed with whatever Firearms they could
get their hands on the rest of the
devotees of the tentacled god brother
Marsh included would attack the
containment site head on in the ensuing
chaos the five cultists who had already
infiltrated the site could take
advantage of the distraction and break
into the containment chamber
was perfect they launched their attack
from the outside and from within when
brother Marsh declared that the time was
right the assault began a legion of gun
wielding cult is seen to Spring out of
nowhere and started shooting up the
warehouse that was a front for the
containment site the site quickly
mobilized guards and task force members
to take on the sudden threat and just as
brother Marsh had anticipated the site
director called on the majority of town
9 to help repel the violent cultists
from their perimeter townai obeyed
leaving three task force members behind
a guard
scp-2662's containment chamber they
expected to be guarding the cell from
rampaging religious zealots seeking an
audience with their God what they didn't
expect was a group of five Foundation
employees walking right up to them and
opening fire killing two townai members
and taking the third as hostage while
the war was being waged outside the
infiltrators had found the tentacle
God's containment cell in the low-risk
humanoid War their hostage insisted that
using him wouldn't give them any
leverage the rest of his team would
neutralize the whole group him included
if that's what it took to stop them the
infiltrators explained that using him as
leverage was never their intention he
wasn't a hostage at all he was a
sacrifice
the cultists of the tentacled god
detonated explosives creating a hole in
the wall and finally giving them access
to their deity they climbed through and
gazed upon him in awe there stood
scp-2662 twice as tall as a regular man
with 10 huge tentacles emerging from its
back and are months of envisioning this
creature they'd pictured it sitting on a
throne made of thousands of human bones
ready to dictate its commands to the
obedient liberators what they certainly
didn't expect was to see the tentacled
god hunched over a computer screen still
God's work in mysterious ways so they
stuck to the plan and began chanting
they pulled out a sacrificial dagger and
began sacrificing their captured tau9
member it was at this point that
scp-2662 turned and saw what they were
doing with a look of pure horror he rose
up from his computer his headphones
getting caught as he did so he told them
to go away that he didn't want them here
and that them murdering people in his
bedroom like this was inconsiderate and
disgusting the cultists became even more
confused why wasn't their God accepting
their offerings what were they doing
wrong they tried more chanting and
painting Arcane symbols on the floor and
blood but this just seemed to make the
creature angrier he told them in a tone
more fitting for a teenage boy than a
lovecraftian God to just leave him alone
so he could play his video games this
was seriously not cool the cultists were
baffled they told the tentacled god that
they were there to free him he replied
that he didn't need saving
that crazy stalkers like them were why
he turned himself into the foundation in
the first place before the cultist
infiltrators could get another word in
the remaining members of town 9 stormed
into the containment cell and gunned
them down with surgical Precision the
war outside was already over brother
Marsh and the rest of the cultists were
all killed in the firefight Town 9
didn't look the least bit surprised upon
entering 2662's cell this was a common
occurrence Unfortunately they had to
deal with an attempted cult Invasion
every few months because
scp-2662's main anomalous ability is
inspiring violent Colts who relentlessly
track down and worship it with Arcane
and bloodthirsty rituals the problem is
2662 doesn't do this consciously and
definitely doesn't like the results
that's why he's under the voluntary care
of the SCP Foundation who keeps him
amused with video games and reading
material while fending off the deranged
Cults who try to invade and abduct him
following the termination of the
devotees of the tentacled God just one
of many Cults who'd broken into 2662's
containment cell the remaining Town nine
members apologized to the tentacled
creature for the disturbance allowing
him to return to his gaming they assured
him that it'd probably be at least a few
more months before something like this
happened again
scp-2662's cell was repaired and the
foundation returned to its task of
seeking out would-be cult emancipators
because for the SCP Foundation it's not
always about the anomaly that's being
kept in containment but what's being
kept down the fabric of our world is
littered with strange doorways if you
know where to look for them tares
portals anomalies all leading to places
and planes Beyond human imagining and
understanding an
scp-2317 otherwise known as a door to
another world certainly fits that
description
contained and kept at all times under
the watch of armed guards
scp-2317 appears to be a simple and
unsuspecting wooden door in its frame
it hardly looks like it requires such
extreme round-the-clock security or
needs a strange secretive ritual that
the foundation performs presumably to
keep the door closed
but of course sometimes the most
interesting thing about a closed doorway
isn't where it leads it's what it keeps
out
even by the foundation's already high
standards
the requirements and regulations for
personnel who are assigned to scp-2317
seem oddly specific psychological
testing is standard practice to work for
the foundation but an additional hurdle
that anyone has to clear before even
getting to Glimpse at this unassuming
wooden door is having a score of at
least 72 on the Milgram obedience
examination
it is also mandatory that Personnel
assigned to maintaining it are both
unmarried with no children or next of
kin as well as an unwavering
unquestioning loyalty to the foundation
pure devotion to its code and objectives
these may seem like strange requirements
after all
scp-2317 is just a door isn't it
perhaps there's a reason that the
foundation keeps so much of the
information about
scp-2317 buried deep under layers upon
layers of security with only the
overseer Council privy to the full
details of its strange nature
knowledge as they say is power but maybe
knowing too much about whatever is
behind that door can prove deadly
still if scp-2317 is a door to another
world an alternate Dimension or parallel
reality it must be safe enough to visit
after all the foundation has been
sending Personnel in there on a regular
basis daily in fact
according to the o5 council this is done
as part of a procedure to maintain
active containment of something lurking
beyond that old wooden door frame
but what could possibly Warren such
constant maintenance and surveillance
in accordance with the foundation's
guidelines all staff are required to
rotate out of observing scp-2317 after
every two months and spend the following
third month in full psychological
counseling before they are permitted to
return to the containment unit housing
the door to another world
it was after one of these month-long
periods of evaluation that a foundation
guard was informed that his security
clearance has been raised to level three
and that he'd been selected for the duty
of carrying out 220 Calabasas he knew
the name instantly
this was the title given to the Daily
containment procedure that absolutely
had to be carried out
the guard didn't question these orders
after all he'd been selected precisely
because of his loyalty to the foundation
he did make one request to his
commanding officer however
he wanted to know what had happened to
the last guard that had performed the
procedure
didn't make it out of psychological
evaluation
the officer replied
not letting this affect his dedication
the guard was told to prepare for
procedure 220 Calabasas
along with a fellow member of foundation
security personnel the guard was
instructed to gather everything on a
strange list
the first was a pre-selected member of
Class D personnel
specifically a convicted murderer class
D refers to disposable class Personnel
Expendable individuals recruited by the
foundation for the sole purpose of
testing scps
class D's were usually prison inmates
repurposed for SCP testing and the one
chosen for 220 Calabasas was no
exception serving multiple life
sentences for murders or at least that's
what the guard had been told
a foundation Personnel member instructed
him to refer to the class D solely as
the assistant from that point on
next the guard collected a live chicken
an obsidian edged knife a silver
asparagulum and aspersorium to be filled
with 500 cc's of holy water that have
been blessed by a priest of the
abrahamic faith and finally a one
kiloton nuclear device which according
to instructions was only to be detonated
in the unlikely events of a catastrophic
containment failure in other words The
Last Resort
after following his instructions to the
letter and without question the guard
and his colleague were briefed the
foundation Personnel member informed
them that he'd be joining and leading
them in the procedure the staff member
also specified that henceforth he'd be
referred to as the celebrant until the
completion of 220 Calabasas the guard
was acutely aware of how specific these
instructions were but trusted in the
foundation knowing that if they wanted
this procedure performed a certain way
then it was in everyone's best interest
to carry out the orders to the letter
but what the celebrant then went on to
explain raised far more questions about
scp-2317s and the nature of procedure
220 Calabasas
the class D joining them wasn't actually
a Class D
the assistant as they were now referred
to was in reality another Foundation
staff member with a level 4 security
clearance specifically tailored to
scp-2317
every member of Staff entering through
scp-2317 and taking an active role in 22
Calabasas needed to be informed that
this assistant was not to be harmed or
treated as a member of disposable class
fighting back the nagging question of
why the foundation would employ this
subterfuge the guard along with his
fellow security officer the celebrant
and assistant prepared for their
departure through the door to another
world at solar noon when the sun was
highest over scp-2317
solar noon chickens and holy water
this all seemed like an oddly occult
combination for the foundation
as they entered the old wooden door
Beyond lay a Barren salt plain
stretching out for kilometers in every
direction
this alternate Dimension according to
the briefing was designated
scp-2317 Prime the guard immediately
noticed a ring of Seven Pillars directly
ahead of the group as they entered
each of them bearing intricately
detailed Engravings unlike anything from
any era of ancient history
procedure 220 Calabasas was carried out
quickly but carefully the guard watching
as the celebrant and assistant were
careful not to miss a step
first the celebrant scattered holy water
into the center of the pillars with the
aspergillum and aspersorium looking down
at his feet and keeping a steady Pace as
he stepped counterclockwise around them
the guard watched intently as the
celebrant completed his circuit around
the pillars and turned to the assistant
anointing his head with holy water
Seven Seals seven rings
seven Thrones for the Scarlet King he
said aloud
the assistant with the obsidian blade in
his hand took the chicken and dispatched
it in sacrifice
letting its blood mix with the holy
water
he then repeated the celebrant circuit
in the opposite direction before
stepping into the center of the stone
pillars
blood for the old gods water for the new
king the assistant recited pouring the
remaining mix of blood and holy water
over a patch of salt in the middle of
the Seven Pillars
even though he knew it wasn't his place
to question the foundation as the 220
Calabasas procedure took place the guard
couldn't help but wonder what all this
was for
it seems so ritualistic like something
deeply religious or even magical he
never bought into all that occult mumbo
jumbo even while working for the
foundation but he had learned not to
question anything even the strangest and
most inexplicable of science
little did he know that beneath his feet
was an ancient and unknowable horror a
beast Chained and lying in weight
contained in a chamber directly
underneath the pillars sat an impossibly
large creature
humanoid and obese its body covered
entirely in Scales thicker than armor
plating
branch-like horns protruded from its
jawless head pointing up to chains that
hung from the Seven Pillars above
each one hooked into the entity's back
all but one of the chains was broken a
final withering shackle keeping the
Devourer of Worlds and its underground
prison
ever since 1894 BCE when origin Mystics
imprisoned it the Devourer has been
waiting patiently for its inevitable
freedom it knows as well as the
foundation that nothing can be done to
prevent the final chain from one day
breaking even procedure 220 Calabasas
won't keep the creature contained
it's nothing more than a smoke screen an
act designed to create an illusion of
active containment and maintain
Foundation morale until a permanent
solution can be devised to keep
scp-2317 imprisoned of course if the
guard had known this it would have also
explained the need for a one kiloton
nuclear device as part of this stage
ritual
procedure 220 Calabasas had all the
components to trick everyone below the
o5 council emulating religious and
occult rituals The increased level of
security surrounding the procedure and
its purpose
and telling staff that any failure to
correctly and completely perform the 220
Calabasas procedure will result in an XK
Class end of the world scenario
all these elements work together to
conceal the truth that one day the
Devourer will escape and lay waste to
our dimension
knowledge is power and maybe knowing too
much truly is deadly perhaps if the
guard had learned any of this he'd have
understood why his predecessor never
made it out of psychological evaluation
maybe if he had questioned the purpose
of procedure 220 Calabasas he'd have
learned the true nature of scp-2317
and what that doorway kept out
but he was loyal to the foundation
through and through
as the team finished performing 220
Calabasas and returned through the
wooden door the guard took one last
glance over his shoulder at the vast
salt plane
the entire Dimension was calm silent
but not peaceful it was patient The
Entity had waited centuries for its time
and now all it would take was the
breaking of the seventh and final chain
one day the door was closed behind the
guard as he the celebrant the assistant
and his fellow security officers stepped
back through
their work done and as far as they knew
preventing catastrophe for another day
only the foundation higher-ups the
overseer Council are aware of the true
danger posed by
scp-2317 and its sole inhabitant
current predictions are that at some
point within the next 30 Years the
Devourer of Worlds will be freed
any and all attempts to repair or
recreate the chains holding it in place
have so far failed as such the o5
council has elected to continue
providing Foundation personnel with the
ignorant hope that procedure 220
Calabasas is an effective strategy for
containment as we've said
sometimes the most interesting thing
about a closed door isn't where it leads
it's what it keeps out
in the case of
scp-2317 the unassuming wooden door
holds at Bay an ancient creature of
Untold power
that will one day break free and wreak
havoc in our dimension
nothing the foundation does can prevent
it or keep it contained behind the door
to another world
and only the overseer Council knows that
any and all efforts to do so are futile
with all that in mind we can only hope
that the doorway of
scp-2317 stays closed
at least for a little while longer
it was November 20th 2019 and the
helicopter circled far above in the
freezing wind of the Antarctic SCP
Foundation site director Jason Monroe
looked down at the isolated above ground
facilities of provisional site 344-1
something about this place made him
nervous edgy and for good reason between
2003 and 2019 29 mobile task force units
and 73 members of d-class personnel had
gone missing here and never been found
Monroe thought he was here for a routine
investigation into negligence and
mismanagement but little did he know he
was in for so much more this is the
story of
scp-5545 and one man's journey into his
own worst nightmare literally but this
nightmare began a long time ago 300
years to be exact and like most
nightmares it started as a dream that
dream was one of expansion National
Powers across your Europe wanted to be
the first to conquer the globe and
expand into new territories and sent
countless exploratory missions off into
the unknown to achieve this goal any
history book will tell you that the
first Outsiders to lay eyes upon the
continent of Antarctica did so in 1820
the reality is that the first ones to
get there actually landed in the late
1700s the hapless explorers ventured
into Mainland Antarctica and made base
camps before searching and digging for
any useful resources nearby They Came
Upon a strange Discovery a hallway
hidden beneath the ice not a passage in
the ice but a true hallway complete with
light fixtures the confused explorers
ventured down into these impossible
hallways and for many of them it would
be the last thing they ever did no
matter how long they walked it seemed
like the hallways just kept going as
they continued to walk for hours they
hoped to find something anything and
eventually they did they pass from these
hallways into somewhere different
altogether and most of them were never
heard from again those who did manage to
escape often died or took their own
lives soon after whatever it was they
discovered down there they didn't want
to live with it on their minds it's
believed that over 70 Colonial explorers
disappeared or died this way and that
most who found these endless hallways
beneath the Antarctic Ice never returned
the multiple anomalous objects and
phenomena that make up
scp-5545 came into the foundation's
hands several centuries later on
September 18 2003 when during an
expedition into the Antarctic they too
found the endless hallways the
foundation-built provisional site 344-1
around them hoping to safely seal them
off from any other unwitting Antarctic
explorers or researchers but there was
something else lurking beneath the ice
in Antarctica something dangerous the
hallways were designated as scp-55 545-1
and were thought to be the extent of the
anomalous activity at the site but soon
as CP
5545-2 was discovered which resulted in
the deaths of 16 researchers so what
exactly is
5545-2 it's an entity so volatile that
even knowing about it is considered to
be a Containment Breach and as a result
it's kept in provisional side
344-2 unlike site 344-1
344-2 isn't a physical space it's
conceptual accessible only through the
endless hallways created with the
express purpose of keeping 5545-1 and
5545-2 separate why because whenever the
two come into contact the result is
5545-3 the network of endless hallways
expanding if they remained in contact
the hallways would continue to expand
and the entire planet could be filled
with endless hallways in just four to
six
while the two are apart though
55-45-3 reverses but it always would
take just a few hours to throw the whole
world into a chaos of infinite hallways
scp-5545 has been given the
classification safe wait we're dealing
with a mysterious and volatile anomaly
that claimed a huge number of lives and
still somehow eludes True Foundation
understanding via the official SCP
Foundation classification is safe how
could the speed Monroe was the director
of site 58 and was the definition of
no-nonsense prior to taking the site
director position he was a decorated
member of mobile task force 8-10 and
helped contain numerous ketter class
anomalies he'd been around the
proverbial block when it came to
anomalous activity and something about
scp-5545 and the management of
provisional site 344 seemed awfully
suspicious to him and he had questions
like how such an unpredictable anomaly
could be declared safe and why had there
been such a lapse of communication
between the foundation and Dr Gabriel
Reed who'd been running the facility for
the past two decades and most of all
just what exactly was the mysterious
scp-5545-2 Monroe started to believe
that something terrible had happened at
the site and Reed was covering it all up
but to find out for sure you'd need to
go to Antarctica and investigate it
himself information about this
supposedly safe anomaly was highly class
fight those without o5 clearance could
face termination for snooping but that
didn't scare Jason Monroe he dealt with
Cutters before he could deal with this
or so he thought Monroe submitted a
request and was granted unanimous
approval by the o5 council to travel to
provisional site 344 and get to the
bottom of this mystery he took a chopper
to the base soon after armed with a
concealed firearm and a hostile meme
detector or hmd to test whether the base
and its staff had somehow Fallen under a
hazardous memetic effect from
scp-5545 he'd find the answers or die
trying the moment Monroe arrived he
couldn't help but notice the strange way
the staff behaved they seemed listless
almost oppressive when he showed his
credentials to a researcher they simply
said
scp-5545-2 is contained inside 344-2 his
request to see Dr Reed that night was
denied Dr Reed was busy he was told wait
until tomorrow the next day Dr Monroe
met with Dr Reed but the results of the
meeting were underwhelming to say the
least just like the rest of the staff on
the site he seemed exhausted as though
he hadn't slept in days his responses
were quiet and evasive and he refused to
tell Monroe anything that wasn't in the
official files already Monroe ran the
conversation through the hmd and found
nothing out of the ordinary what was
going on here Monroe was irritated but
not to turn nothing would stop him from
finding out the truth
the next day he flexed his o5
credentials and hacked into the base's
security system this gave him access to
cameras around site 344-1 but more
importantly there was a single camera
inside the mysterious site
344-2 jackpot but when he looked at it
the feed was an entirely black screen
with the words
scp-5545-2 is contained in site
344-2 the footage of the staff in 344-1
was equally strange the 18 employees on
site all sat at computer banks with
nothing but static playing on their
screens Monroe kept digging though and
was able to hack into the security
footage of Dr Reed's office as he
watched he discovered a 15-minute period
where Reed left the office each day he
could use this brief window to break in
and collect more Intel on
scp-5545-2 Monroe was so wrapped up in
the investigation that he almost forgot
the more immediate Danger around him and
nearly wandered into one of the Endless
hallways of 5545-1 by mistake he made a
note to be more careful in the future
his first attempt at breaking into Dr
Reed's office didn't produce many
answers one piece of evidence was a
blurry picture of what looked like a
mobile task force entering a 55-45-1
hallway in the dark another was a
spreadsheet featuring all the Personnel
living or dead who worked at the site
but one name and the details of whether
this person was alive or dead was
completely redacted anything
particularly juicy was hidden behind o5
clearance if Monroe wanted the answers
he needed to break through that night he
had a horrific reoccurring nightmare one
that had plagued him since he joined MTF
at a 10 he dreamed that he was in a
fancy dining room with a grand fireplace
the room was full of statues of men and
women the men looked angry and the woman
looked afraid as he approached the
fireplace the ceiling extended
infinitely up into the darkness suddenly
the zombie-like body of a teenage girl
appears in the fireplace hanging from a
long thread her eyes look Furious and
full of rage and Monroe somehow knows
that he's the reason for her head when
he steps into the fireplace in this
stream she attacks him the two
intertwine and they burn forever the one
difference was that in this new
iteration of the dream he blinked upon
entering the fireplace and suddenly he
was in the hallway he woke sure that
something was terribly wrong here but he
couldn't give up now the next day Dr
Monroe broke into Reed's office and made
a horrifying Discovery he found files
indicating that Dr Reed was knowingly
sending mobile task forces and d-class
Personnel into the infinite hallways of
5545-1 to their Doom he also found
evidence that Reed and the researchers
had been spying on him somehow
intercepting copies of the notes he had
been taking that's when Dr Reed entered
the office and interrupted him Monroe
panicked and Drew his weapon holding the
doctor at gunpoint he was breaking so
many Foundation rules but right now he
feared for his life the doctor seemed
unbothered by Monroe's threats though he
told Monroe that everything was going to
plan and that he should go back to his
room Monroe was becoming increasingly
paranoid he felt that at any moment
guards my first in and execute him
nothing about this place made sense he
worried he was going insane perhaps the
only way to find answers was to go even
deeper to risk it all and Venture
through the endless hallways to find
scp-5545-2 himself and finally discover
what thing actually was Monroe left his
room and stepped into one of the Endless
hallways of 5545-1 that was located just
across from his dorm he found that it
was a hallway like all the others on
site playing concrete one of age with
simple light fixtures on the walls he
walked for hours recording with a
concealed device the light suddenly went
out leaving him in complete darkness
when they flicked back on he was in a
very different environment a grand old
carpeted hallway the kind you'd see in
an old mansion he broke into a cold
sweat what was so familiar about this
place
walking racked with Terror until this
new hallway finally led him to the place
he'd been seeking site
344-2 the domain of
5545-2 it was a large poorly lit room
filled with grimacing statues and a
large fireplace at the far end it was
the exact same room from Monroe's dream
with one horrifying difference Monroe
noticed a single white thread hanging
down from the infinite ceiling and when
he looked up to find its source he
screamed there were hundreds of bodies
hanging and swinging from the ceiling
above him everyone who
scp-5545-2 had ever killed including MTF
members d-class personnel and even the
colonial explorers from hundreds of
years before and all of them were him
every single one they had his face and
there hanging in the middle of the room
at ground level was the body of a
teenage girl the one from his dream that
moment he finally recognized her she was
the girl he killed the first hymn
hundreds of years ago much like Monroe
you're probably wondering what is going
on here thanks to Declassified
communication between Dr Reed and the o5
council we can tell you Jason Monroe was
a man who's been reincarnated hundreds
of times over the last 300 years ever
since he murdered a teenage girl a girl
named Emily his daughter this murder
sparked the existence of
scp-5545 as an eternally reoccurring
punishment for his crimes since figuring
this out the foundation has kept tabs on
Monroe's reincarnations whether they're
MTF members d-class Personnel or even
psych directors they see to it that
these reincarnations always find their
way back to
5545-2 to take his punishment and
prevent the infinite hallway expansion
that threatens to destroy the world it's
a plan everyone is in on everyone except
but every time he enters that nightmare
hunting room it all comes rushing back
in that moment though he knew his crime
and he somehow knew how many times this
punishment had unfolded for him he now
had two choices repent and accept the
punishment again or leave and activate
5545-3 potentially allowing the endless
tunnels to expand across the world like
his many predecessors Monroe made the
decent Choice he accepted his punishment
and allowed his own string to coil
around him as the lights in the room
went off one by one leaving only
Darkness Jason Monroe that version of
him at least was never seen again but
the SCP Foundation is already eyeing up
his next reincarnation and preparing to
let this Twisted cycle play out all over
again you're a pizza delivery person for
a company were not at Liberty to name it
may seem like a thankless job but you're
part of the thin cross between
satisfaction and star Innovation for
people who really don't feel like
cooking or going out tonight you're a
tried and true Pizza veteran you've seen
a lot on the job from people who try to
rob you on their own doorsteps to one
guy who tried to tip you with a clearly
fake Rolex but you haven't seen anything
like the insanity you're about to
encounter tonight that's because you're
about to get sick really really sick and
we know there's probably a lot of
diseases you'd rather not catch but
trust us no disease bites quite like
scp-3760 but back to you you're parked
on the saddle of your prize bicycle
pedaling for your life the biggest order
you've ever delivered strapped to the
cargo rack behind you eight large Meat
Feast pizzas you figure you're heading
towards the most hopping or at least the
hungriest party in the city and despite
the frustration of needing to Ferry this
hot cheesy nightmare to its destination
parties have historically been pretty
good tippers little do you know you your
prize customer is about to give you much
more than just a tip you pull outside
their ground level apartment and park
your bike there's no music coming from
the apartment you're heading to strange
you pick up your precious cargo and
trudge towards the door barely managing
to ring the bell with your spare Pinky
the door swings open instantly as though
the occupant was just standing behind it
the whole time waiting for you when the
door opens you're not sure what to make
of what you see inside there isn't a
party there doesn't even seem to be a
group just one person standing there and
staring at you and something about this
person is just wrong his skin seems to
be an oddly unnatural color it has a
slightly gray Hue like it's rotting and
you see that the stranger shirt is torn
in several places you're trying your
best to remain professional and not
stare but you notice that whatever is
under these tears doesn't look like skin
it's almost like there are holes all
over his body underneath the shirt big
gaping holes and are those you're cut
off when he takes the pile of pizzas
from you and shoves what was once a
handful of dollars into your palm they
seem torn up and worst of all wet you
look past your strange customer and see
that his apartment looks just as shoddy
as he does there's stuffing torn from
the couch huge tears in the curtains
when you could swear or scratch or bite
marks on some of the wooden furniture
this man clearly needed his pizza as you
begin to step away happy to just be rid
of this freaky situation you do
something that you'll live to regret
just for a moment you lock eyes with the
customer there's something about them
that makes you feel sick they're wet and
black more like a doll's eyes than
anything that should belong to a human
just that one instant of contact is
enough to chill your bones and according
to some theories around
scp-3760 it may have been the moment
your infection as the stranger closes
the door in your face presumably to eat
his obscene number of pizzas you stumble
back to your bicycle letting your torn
up Gooey tip Blow Away In The Wind
getting out of this place is rewarding
enough but you can't chase the thoughts
of the stranger out of your mind was he
sick was he even human these are the
thoughts swimming through your head as
you cycle back to the restaurant you're
so preoccupied you don't even notice the
truck speeding towards you you get
sideswiped destroying your bike and
throwing you in the air you can feel the
snap of your arm breaking as you land
it's a horrible feeling to go along with
the horrible noise and as you fade from
Consciousness the last thought in your
mind is the black soulless eyes of the
customer when you wake up you'll find
that you're in a hospital bed with your
arm in a cast The Doctors tell you that
you're phenomenally lucky to be alive
given the severity of the crash the
doctor says that you're dealing with a
compound fracture in your right arm as
well as some nasty cuts that required
stitches but otherwise you're fine the
hospital insists that you at least stay
the night though and you oblige but that
night you find it's difficult to sleep
partially because of the pain but mostly
because of an extremely strange sound
coming from inside the cast around your
arm it's a scraping noise like something
sharp scratching at the interior you
figure it must just be some strange side
effect of the pain meds you're not going
to let worry eat you up on the inside
something else will be doing that soon
enough you're discharged from the
hospital the next day and told that you
should be fine in a couple of months as
though that's some kind of consolation
you try to carry on with your daily life
as much as you can with one arm out of
commission but that awful crunching
noise from inside your cast persists you
even start to become paranoid that some
sort of insect is trapped inside or
worse a swarm of insects but you aren't
left without certainty for Long by the
next morning your cast has fallen off
will not Fallen per se a more accurate
description would be that it was chewed
off from the inside and not by something
trapped in there with your arm but by
your arm itself when you finally see it
it doesn't even look like an arm anymore
the flesh has turned gray that same
sickly gray of the customer's skin the
night of your accident but worse still
from the top of the hand down to the
base of the forearm your entire arm is
split open into a Fang lying chattering
mouth when you've gotten over the
initial horror of seeing the mutations
that have taken hold of your arm you
notice something about the teeth in the
second mouth they're nothing like human
teeth their vicious Jagged triangles
each one like a dagger these are
unmistakably shark's teeth you give
yourself the luxury of having a good
screen after all what else are you
supposed to do after you find your arm
as turned into some kind of fleshy shark
mutant you notice that you can hardly
even feel the snapping of its jaws like
it isn't even really a part of you and
as much as you try to tense and release
what used to be the tendons in your
forearm there is no change for all
intents and purposes that limb is no
longer yours it just happens to be
attached to you not only that but it's
always very very hungry as quickly
became evident from the fact it made
such short work of the cast that had
been containing it not long ago you can
see that the graying flesh is beginning
to spread from your forearm to your
bicep it's almost like little by little
your tissue is being switched somehow
you're innately aware that if you don't
feed your arm it'll get even worse
suddenly everything about the strange
customer from the night of the accident
makes sense he had whatever you have now
only worse it was just hoping that the
pizzas would keep the beast at Bay and
you very much hope the contents of your
fridge will do the same wasting no time
line you grab some processed ham and raw
chicken you're not an idiot you know
that if this thing is anything like a
real shark it's only going to be
interested in meat but when you shove
the processed meat into the nibbling maw
in your forearm you notice that it seems
to spit the food out something tells you
that your offering was too dead now
you're really afraid will this thing
want life prey will that be the only way
to stop it from taking the rest of your
arm or even more the thought terrifies
you it's like being Venom except you
don't even get a new alien friend or any
cool superpowers for your trouble but
you're smart you're resourceful you
don't intend to let this thing take over
your life without a fight and you've
always believed what GI Joe taught you
knowing is half the battle sadly doing
an internet search for my injury is
somehow mutating into a shark how do I
stop this didn't do much good and you
don't want to go to a doctor because
part of you expects to be immediately
shipped off to the nearest circus or
military research lab instead you throw
on a thick leather jacket that you hope
your new shark arm will take a while to
eat through and head to the library of
the nearest medical college if anywhere
has sources on the most obscure of
medical problems this would be the place
and after hours of searching through
index cards you find it what seems to be
the one and only source of this
ludicrous Topic in the thousands and
thousands of books a series of journal
entries made by Dr Keith Woodward ship's
medical officer aboard the USS Kirby
Circa 1922 even the library's indexing
system prefaces the source with a
disclaimer that it's likely 25 quackery
and 75 ocean Madness but that doesn't
deter you any poured in the storm Dr
Woodward told the horrifying tale of the
USS Kirby's collapse due to a sudden and
unexplainable contagion it began with
the infection of a sailor on the ship
named Willis Riggs who'd Fallen
overboard and had his foot partially
eaten by a shark much like your arm the
man's foot slowly became the ravenous
all-devouring mouth of a shark itself
little by little it spread to the other
crew members through unknown means any
injury sustained by the crew didn't heal
like normal but instead became this
vicious living shark tissue soon these
ever hungry new mouths LED them to eat
each other and then themselves from the
inside out even after the humans they
once were could be considered long dead
those hungry Jaws kept snapping there
was no cure there was no solution
everyone on the boat was recorded as
having mysteriously died at Sea that is
the curse of
scp-3760 and as if On Cue you look down
to see that the shark's mouth in your
arm has chewed through the leather of
your sleeve like it's nothing it's
hungry and nothing will satiate it but
perhaps some sacrifices need to be made
if you want to stop it from getting
worse just as the thought crosses your
mind a needle full of sedative is
injected into your neck everything goes
dark very quickly and when you wake up
you're in a clean clinical white room
you are now officially under containment
by the SCP Foundation not that you'll
know that anytime soon this may seem
like the calvary has arrived but sadly
for your sake they have no interest in
curing you they're just eager to gather
more data on how your condition
progresses
scp-3760 exists as a latent infection in
well over half of humanity but its
horrific mutating effects are activated
in only a relative few there have only
been
2785 recorded cases of scp-3760 activity
observed between 1958 and
2016. this is thanks to the foundation's
secret weapon against the shark mutation
Menace subliminal memetic age and Kappa
Omicron or smako a widely distributed
memetic agent that suppresses the
symptoms of infection in most people not
that this would provide much comfort to
you as you joined the almost 3 000
others who have been infected and you
are doomed to slowly turn into an
abomination in your containment chamber
if it's any consolation you may not see
the truly Advanced stages of the disease
the most common cause of death Among The
Afflicted is being eaten by their own
ravenous shark mouths long before it
changes your entire body actually come
to think of it that's not much of a
consolation at all but hey when it comes
to anomalous mutations we're sad to
report that there's rarely a happy
ending in store for those Afflicted and
scp-3760 is no exception to the rule
picture the shyest female friend
relative or loved one you know a real
introvert she can't stand parties and
playing the dating game is her idea of a
living hell you won't catch her dead in
a bar but imagine someday Everything
Changes she's suddenly more relaxed more
outgoing she goes out to parties and now
you you keep seeing her with this one
guy again and again and again it seems
like these days all she does is spend
time with this guy and to think he's
never even introduced himself to you
he's practically a total stranger but
your friend seems happy enough so it
doesn't bother you until one day
something strange happens
your friend just starts screaming you
can explain it she can't explain it her
doctor can't explain it nobody can
explain it all you know is that for
months on end she has involuntary
screaming fits like something out of a
nightmare but still she always smiles
she seems happy as long as you don't
look at her eyes there's something oddly
glassy about them they seem plastic dead
your friend is experiencing a dangerous
phenomenon known to the SCP Foundation
as
scp-3512 an anomaly that only seems to
affect women between the ages of 18 and
40. one woman is already dead as a
result of this and an additional nine
others affected by this strange anomaly
have been cataloged and contained in
standard humanoid containment Chambers
for study at first the foundation
couldn't draw any logical conclusions
for why these women were spontaneous
experiencing total personality changes
and pronounced screaming fits all the
foundation had to go on was that the
first cluster of infected individuals
originated in Barcelona Spain a
foundation facility in Boston dispatched
one of their best field operatives agent
Riley Cooper on an investigative mission
to Barcelona they wanted her to get to
the bottom of this phenomenon and put a
stop to it before things went any
further while in Spain agent Cooper
would be assisted by a local Foundation
operative agent Palmas Ray whose
intimate knowledge of the Locale would
provide a key advantage in the
investigation together they'd crack this
thing and make sure no other women were
harmed at least that's what the
foundation had hoped instead both agents
disappeared under horrific circumstances
during the investigation and today we're
going to tell you about the final days
of agent Cooper and agent Rey and why
attempting to investigate SCP 3512 was
the last thing they ever did agent
Cooper arrived on the 15th of July 2016
and stepped out into the scorching
summer heat of Spain agent Cooper was
everything you'd want in a field
operative for the foundation intelligent
dedicated and professional she
rendezvoused with agent Ray who was a
comparatively smooth and laid-back
figure the two of them began their
investigation by speaking to the friends
and families of some of the infected
women pretending to be doctors working
for the World Health Organization agent
Cooper in her personal Diaries noted how
creepy and unreal the affected women
seemed most of the interviews were
unnerving and sad but not exactly
enlightening however as things Drew to a
close a younger sister of one of the
victims mentioned a single word blackout
even the mention of the word caused the
victim to descend into another screaming
fit agent raised local knowledge came in
handy once again he recognized the name
it was a popular local nightclub agent
Cooper and agent Ray knew they had to
investigate the club and went undercover
as regular patrons for the first several
hours they were there nothing happened
but then at 2 am a man approached agent
Cooper at the bar he was a tall blonde
man with an unsettling intensity to him
he asked without a hint of irony what
agent Cooper's favorite star was there
was something off about this man his
word choice was too precise almost
rehearsed he wasn't drunk in the
slightest agent Cooper intuited that
this was the kind of guy who liked to
take advantage of women in bars when she
threw a glance at agent Ray signaling
him that something was off the stranger
quickly laughed for agent Cooper this
only further confirmed her suspicions
the agents paid off the bouncer to find
out if the tall stranger was a regular
and then what his name was after being
slip some cash the bouncer was all too
eager to share the strange man came here
all the time and he knew his name too it
was Jose Oriole agent Cooper and agent
Rey wasted no time in finding Jose
Oreo's apartment and receiving
authorization to perform a comprehensive
search on the premises and as soon as
they did they found cause to declare the
man a person of interest in the scp-3512
investigation the apartment was a
smorgasbord of suspicious activity
Oriole was a software developer but he
had extensive records on the
architecture of the local area including
buildings utilities and Railway tunnels
Josef correctly figured the
investigators were coming for him and
had fled his home before they could get
there and this was only the tip of the
iceberg agent Cooper and Rey then found
a book with a plain cover sitting on
audio's kitchen table Cooper thought it
was a Publisher's proof a kind of
pre-publication prototype copy of a book
they collected it but didn't read it
straight away worrying about its
potentially Cognito hazardous nature and
besides they were a little distracted by
the homemade monstrosity sitting next to
it he'd look to agent Cooper like a
sculpted blob of wax with a series of 12
makeshift legs made from a variety of
substances including Lego pieces Rose
stems a crab claw and a corkscrew Rey
called Cooper into the bathroom where
there were a number of boxes filled with
similar supplies bodkin's quills dolls
limbs wire and syringes when Cooper LED
Rey back into the kitchen to see Oreo's
little art project later classified by
the foundation as
scp-3512-1 they were surprised and
unnerved to see that it was already gone
everything about this situation screamed
anomalous and it only got worse later
that night when Cooper actually read the
book she collected from Oriole's
apartment being sure to wear Cognito
Hazard filtering goggles as a a
precaution the book now known to the SCP
Foundation as
scp-3512-2 was entitled The more you
know a pickup artist's Bible and was
written by a man using the pen name
Enigma as the title suggests it was a
misogynistic
625-page non-fiction book on the subject
of picking up women it even had a
forward on its Effectiveness by popular
American rapper Calvin Broadus Jr better
known as Snoop Dogg though after being
contacted by the foundation Mr dog
claimed no knowledge of the book the
book began with your typical creepy and
dehumanizing seduction tactics for the
first 11 chapters but the following 12
chapters which were each titled chapter
12 delved into increasingly creepy and
esoteric techniques including Advanced
geometric proofs the interpretation of
Dreams do-it-yourself surgical
techniques symbolism and architecture
and anomalous rituals the books
afterward is composed of more than
fifteen thousand anagrams of the book's
title laid out in spiral and triangular
patterns Cooper took a particular morbid
interest in chapter 18 where it appeared
to provide instructions on creating
objects that look like the anomalous
scp-3512-1 sculpture is found in
Oriole's apartment the chapter read make
a rough ball of the materials you've
harvested and place it in the freezer
for 6 to 12 hours pork fat can be used
but will have less satisfactory results
who knew right while you wait you can
prepare the limbs concentrate on
articulation rather than strength you
may want to add simple tools to some
limbs if the object of your desire is
more careful than most but remember that
the more complicated you make them the
more precise your sculpting will need to
be lay your prepared limbs out on a
clean flat surface once you're at pose
preparation has had time to freeze
carefully carve it into the shape you
learned in chapter 12. you will know it
is ready when you see it start smiling
at you now introduce the limbs they
should take almost immediately wait
until your intended is likely to be
sleeping then concentrate your thoughts
on her face and particularly the inside
of her mouth and throat soon you'll see
your new friends Scurry off ready to
help you establish social dominance if
this wasn't disturbing enough the next
chapter advised the use of scissors and
the removal of the aspiring
seductionist's pinky finger as well as
the pinky fingers of their family
members to help increase their seductive
power it appeared to Cooper that these
rituals in seemingly living anomalous
sculptures were behind the scp-3512
phenomena and that night they got their
next break in the case the two agents
had sent the architectural plans found
in Orioles apartment back to Foundation
age q and while most of it was found to
be public records of the local area
there was one notable abnormality a
secret exit in a little used Subway
tunnel that led to a grand spiral
staircase heading down to well they just
didn't know and it was the job of Agents
Cooper and Rey to find out they set out
later that night on what they didn't
know would be the last mission they'd
ever take the two agents descended the
spiral staircase for what felt like ours
until they reached an elaborate system
of tunnels at the bottom they began
exploring the tunnels and found that
they were cramped and covered in strange
ritualistic carvings occasionally they
even saw clusters of human pinky fingers
sticking out of the wall they kept going
and soon found that whatever they were
moving towards was loud immensely hot
and the smell was truly horrific as the
almost deafening mechanical drone got
louder and louder and the smell grew
worse they knew they must be getting
closer to whatever was happening here
the tunnel soon opened up to a giant
chamber where they found something truly
horrific in front of them was what
looked to be an entire River of bubbling
liquid human fat the exact kind that the
author Enigma had recommended using to
create the mind-altering
scp-3512-1 sculptures in his book and
speaking of the book across the river
agent Cooper and agent Ray noticed a
complex series of printing presses
presumably churning out more copies of
the more you know a pickup artist Bible
to spread its anomalous influence far
and wide however before the duo could
literally stop the presses they were
attacked a huge 3512-1 entity with legs
made out of human spines jumped down
from the ceiling it latched on to agent
Cooper embedding her in its waxy body
and dragging her into the disgusting
with of hot fat agent Ray was separated
and lost in the tunnels presumed dead as
he hasn't been seen since agent Cooper
however would live to see a far more
horrifying fate she was carried down
river by the greasy tide until her body
was washed up in a different chamber
that looked to be a place of worship
below the Sagrada Familia Basilica
filled with thousands of tiny crawling
3512-1s there she met the creator of all
of this a horrific thing that was
perhaps once a man now covered in
wriggling living pinky fingers sticking
out of its body it was disgusting but
she wouldn't mind for long in fact the
next time Cooper woke up she didn't have
a problem with it at all she was changed
just like all the others another victim
of the scp-3512 phenomenon she was
giggly outgoing and uninhibited all
despite the nightmare Irish situation
she was in she loved the horrifying
monster that had done this to her she
didn't have a choice not to and when he
was tired of her he took her and threw
her down into a large pit in this
chamber the same one where the many dead
bodies of his previous mind-controlled
girlfriends were laying neither agent
was ever seen after this mobile task
force Zeta 9 AKA mole rats have been
sent into the tunnels to investigate but
they didn't find any of the locations
comparable to the ones seen by Cooper
and Rey in their last hours whoever did
all of this is still out there still
dangerous so Ladies If you ever see a
guy you know reading a copy of the more
you know a pickup artist's Bible run
like your life and Sanity depends on it
because this time it really really does
the Ethics Committee is one of the SCP
foundation's most important and
overlooked divisions the small Secret
group keeps a close eye on the
foundation to ensure that all decisions
made and all actions taken are for the
betterment of humanity and not just in
service of needless sadism and cruelty
the Ethics Committee consists of a small
group of people in comparison to the
gargantuan that is the foundation as a
whole it's only natural that every so
often something slips under their radar
and when it does it usually results in
complete and utter disaster in the case
of scpe 4051 that's something is a male
humanoid with a unique ability to open
wormholes to extra-dimensional spaces
and in terms of disaster well let's just
say we hope you have a pretty tight grip
on that red SCP expert coffee mug of
yours the wormholes that scp-4051 opens
are essentially spaces filled with
infinite copies of a single item which
scp-4051 can reach in and pull out
assuming they're small enough that is
the foundation's strict experimentation
schedule has provided a lot of important
data on how scp-4051's anomaly functions
controlled testing showed scp-4051 was
able to manifest small simple objects
like a net sugar pills or drinking water
but he's also claimed or reported to
have manifested many other things like
aluminum baseball bats duct tape and
more at one point
scp-4051 was allowed to use these
abilities to assist with the site but
the Ethics Committee recently halted
this seems like a simple enough anomaly
but with the foundation we all know it
never is so let's go back let's start at
the very beginning the foundation first
became aware of scp-4051 when YouTube
videos surfaced online of a vigilante in
an American city using wormholes to
fight criminals the videos got over 2
million views before the foundation
became aware in August 2012 and stepped
in taking it down and investigating what
had led to it a mobile task force was
dispatched retrieve the individual using
the wormholes and brought scp-4051 back
to site 17. the first interview with
scp-4051 began on a bad note
scp-4051 was handcuffed behind a pane of
glass when Dr Arthur Roswell began to
speak to him Dr Roswell introduced
himself and confirmed that scp-4051's
name was Raynor Miller after being
assured of his safety
scp-4051 calmed down a little and
stopped struggling with the handcuffs at
Dr roswell's request
scp-4051 began to explain the details of
his anomalous power he affirmed that he
could make small objects appear out of
thin air and that he tried to use these
abilities to help people at first he'd
intermittently interrupt carjackings and
robberies subduing the criminal but with
a new Criminal Syndicate moving in the
crime rate skyrocketed requiring Raynor
to patrol much more regularly during
these acts of heroism several witnesses
saw raynor's Powers though he tried to
keep them quiet his request for the
foundation Nation to intervene with a
Criminal situation was acknowledged as
Rainer volunteered any and all
information he had stating that he just
wanted to help the foundation Roswell
thanked him for his enthusiasm it didn't
take long for the foundation to move to
experimenting with rainer's powers as
the foundation often does at first they
started slow Dr Roswell and his
colleague Dr Edwards asked Raynor to
manifest a few small items a metal cube
a bottle of bleach and something of his
choice he was able to produce the cube
without any trouble and the object of
his choice wound up being a framed
picture of his mother when he tried to
take the bleach out he seemed upset but
managed to do it with the experiment to
success
scp-4051 was escorted back to his
containment chamber all the way there he
repeatedly asked how long this testing
phase would take before he would be let
go the staff didn't have an answer for
him in the next test Raynor was asked by
Roswell and Edwards to produce a copy of
War and Peace and a phone both were
produced but the book was filled with
gibberish and the phone was entirely
Hollow the researchers concluded that
the anomaly is based on how well
scp-4051 understands the object being
manifested and mused about requesting
something that didn't exist Raynor still
asked all the researchers how his family
was and whether he would have any
friends at the foundation between tests
the questions were once again ignored by
the staff in the third experiment
Roswell and Edwards asked Raynor to
produce objects that didn't exist a
circular square a color and so on but
scp-4051 wanted to know about his family
and when he would be able to go home
before he would try to manifest anything
Roswell assured him that once the
foundation had a solid grip on his
ability he would be allowed to go home
questions about his family revealed that
his mother believed he was away visiting
colleges he demanded to speak to his
mother before any other experiments and
Roswell affirmed that he'd asked the o5s
for approval when the experiment in
question was finished Vayner agreed and
began the experiment trying to produce
the impossible items what came out were
Cognito hazards severely damaging the
mental state of anyone trying to
perceive them half the research team
instantly collapsed and security guards
subdued Raynor to take him back to his
cell the testing chamber was cleaned and
Dr Edwards wrote that the value of
scp-4051's anomaly was too great to let
him sit in a box unused he called for a
special pediatric therapist and
authorized further experiments on Raynor
but in his own containment cell Raynor
was still knocked out after the test had
gone wrong the cameras watched on as he
woke up and began curling up and away
from them toward the other side of the
room then standing up a few minutes
later he had manifested many small
pieces of body armor and glued them to
his body the guards were distracted with
escorting Roswell and Edwards from the
testing chamber and didn't realize
anything was wrong until Raynor
manifested a small bomb and blew his
door open leaving his cell other
security guards in immediately turned
and responded trying to subdue scp-4051
with non-lethal weapons eventually a few
were able to overpower and incapacitate
Raynor and move him back to his cell the
day after the Containment Breach site
17's director Thomas Graham sent out an
open letter to all staff assigned to
scp-4051 Raynor had been moved to a more
secure containment unit but everyone
agrees that it would be better in the
long run if scp-4051 is working for the
foundation rather than against it
especially with regards to amnestics
sourcing y-909 a chemical used in
amnestics was dangerous and expensive
for the foundation but if raynor's
abilities could be harnessed to produce
amnestics easily then he would be all
the more valuable to them as a friend
rather than a foe the Ethics Committee
also required that scp-4051 do so
voluntarily for the foundation rather
than being forced to produce amnestics
against his will to that Dr Edwards was
promoted to scp-40 51's Project Director
on the basis that he would try to ensure
Raynor would be totally and utterly
loyal to the foundation using whatever
means necessary he already set up a
schedule using punishments and rewards
along with regular checkups from an
on-site therapist the therapy sessions
began on a good note Dr Yesenia the
Therapist assigned to scp-4051
introduced herself politely and Raynor
seemed to take a shine to her they
discussed his unique anomaly and the
Containment Breach incident the azania
was kind and understood the
psychological toll containment had on
people she asked why he wanted to escape
and he explained he just wanted to see
his family he was close with his mother
since his father had walked down on them
when Rainer was just a boy they had been
supporting each other since and he
missed her a lot that said he explained
he wasn't opposed to living at the
foundation they could help him actually
understand his powers and he didn't mind
being a part of tests if he knew he was
helping people he just wanted to see his
family again yesenia's after meeting
notes said that the containment effort
should be focused on assuring brainer
that the foundation had his best
interests in mind the next set of
experiments were a little more abstract
Dr Edwards alone was overseeing them and
the first experiment included another
individual a d-class the plan was to see
if the d-class could also pull things
out of the portals or if only scp-4051
was able to interact with his portals
the d-class was scared of Rainer but
after some urging by Dr Edwards he
managed to touch the sides of the
portals and reach in and pull out a
stone Rainer was only anomalous in his
ability to manifest the portals so
Edward's plan was to cut out the
middleman and to perform research on
scp-4051's brain to see if they could
successfully devise an artificial method
of creating the portals the experiment
after that was to see the bounds and
geographies of the pocket Dimensions
that Raynor generated a GPS tracking
chip was thrown into one of the portals
as cp4051 made specifically the portal
leading to portraits of his mother the
portal shot then Raynor was asked to
recreate it the researchers checked to
see if they could still get a solid
signal from the tracking chip and they
did albeit almost a thousand kilometers
away the results were filed away but
Edwards noticed one thing the portrait
of scp-4051's mother was slightly
different it seemed that he was
forgetting what she looked like the next
therapy appointment with Dr uzenia
covered how Raynor felt about that
experiment he was excited that they were
actually performing research about the
anomaly that he wasn't capable of just
telling them that they were now finding
out something interesting about his
powers izenia asked if he had any
requests for tests but he doubted that
Edwards would listen to anything he said
the doctor seemed to dislike Raynor for
some reason he couldn't figure out but
he knew best on what to test and how
meanwhile Edwards had come up with
something that could utilize
scp-4051's abilities in a useful way for
the project of synthesizing and
domestics procedure 350 Promethean the
details of this clandestine project are
murky and secretive but the goal was to
see if they could use Rainer as a live
method of synthesizing y-909 through an
experimental surgical procedure several
contingencies were planned if the
Wormhole became too dangerous or Rainer
tried to resist he'd be automatically
injected with paralytics and sent back
to his cell the project wasn't
immediately approved though the Ethics
Committee sent one of their most skilled
Liaisons Jeremiah Sumerian to conduct
the approval process he interviewed Dr
Edwards ascertaining that the man was
sane and able to conduct the procedure
that any unethical actions that were
outside of the scope of The Proposal
would result in his removal from the
team and disciplinary action moreover he
revealed that he knew that Dr Roswell
scp-4051's original researcher was
Edward's brother and that he had been
permanently injured in the incident when
Raynor was asked to manifest impossible
objects Edward swore that he wouldn't
take any needless actions to cause
intentional pain and suffering and that
everything he would do would be in
service of the foundation's goals with
that procedure 350 Promethean was
approved meanwhile Dr roswell's
condition wasn't improving he had been
put into an induced coma by medical
personnel due to his extensive exposure
to the Cognito hazards he wasn't
expected to recover anytime soon after
the Ethics Committee approved the
procedure Dr Edwards stopped conducting
usual experiments the very next test
involving scp-4051 was the first
implementation of procedure 350
Promethean but it failed Raynor broke
the restraints on the chair during the
painful procedure and Edwards considered
tranquilizing him but decided against it
we needed a wake he said the next
therapy session though Rainer didn't so
much as mention the procedure instead he
greeted Dr yesnia explaining that he
wasn't doing so well he had talked back
to a guard and they had taken his desk
away as punishment he felt like it was
his own fault Dr Yesenia was worried and
offered to see if she could get the desk
back but he declined the offer saying
he'd just try to be better after this
session Yesenia felt annoyed not by
Rainer but by Edwards he had been saying
that the subject was getting resentful
and rude but Raynor still seemed like a
sweet helpful child the next time
procedure 350 Promethean was enacted it
was the first time Edwards actually
managed to successfully complete it
scp-4051 was actually being compliant
with the procedure making the job a lot
easier for the surgical staff the
results and details of it however were
still unclear in the therapy session
after that Raynor told Dr Yesenia that
he had been having terrible terrible
dreams every night nightmares that
stopped him from sleeping he worried
that people would treat him like a freak
not because of his anomaly but because
of what happened with his father Dr
uzenia encouraged him to tell her she
already knew but felt it would be good
if he let it out and he shared his
memory of how his father had locked him
in a closet and abused him burning him
with bleach that's why he'd been upset
when asked to take a bottle of bleach in
the first test his nightmares were about
not being able to escape something that
was coming toward him and that his
father could still be out there but
yazenia admitted to him that while she
shouldn't be telling him his father had
been found by the foundation he was
serving a life sentence in an Arkansas
prison for murder Banner grew quiet for
a moment before changing the subject
hezenia's observations were optimistic
and she believed his mental health was
improving and that he was now fitting
into his role at the foundation though
she wondered how Edwards experiments
with him were going the next
implementation of procedure 350
Promethean went poorly Edwards wrote in
his diary angrily afterwards that leaner
didn't even remember Roswell or
recognize his name how he was angry that
he was assigned to the anomaly that had
nearly killed his brother yet an
outburst during the experiment and it
was shut down early but only a week
after another attempt was made while the
procedure was being done Raynor asked
about Roswell but was cut off the
research team knew that if he was told
what he had done to Dr Roswell his
mental health would crater and
negatively affect the project in spite
of that the procedure was a success and
Edwards took credit for the whole thing
they were getting closer to being able
to completely make use of
scp-4051s anomaly in his next therapy
session Renner recounted how he liked
being out and about in nature and how
the containment cell had become a
suffocating prison izenia suggested she
might be able to swing a treadmill in
this room to keep him active if she
bothered her superiors but he didn't
want her to get in trouble he seemed
worried and upset he voiced that he
didn't think these experiments were
helping people anymore that he was being
a burden ezenia had an idea she could
ask the director to allow Rainer to help
out around the site fixing little things
and helping clean things up it wasn't
much but but it would allow him some
activity and boost his morale about
helping people all while making use of
his anomaly Rainer was excited he loved
the idea and had been scared about being
stuck in a Cell uselessly after the
session yazenia reflected that it seemed
cruel to manipulate scp-4051 into
wanting to help the foundation when he
so obviously already wants to help and
just like she said it didn't take long
for the director to authorize a security
clearance for scp-4051 just enough to be
outside his cell when accompanied to
help with sight maintenance while Raynor
was off fixing things around the site
izenia decided to do some digging and
asked for information about the
experiments Edwards was conducting but
didn't have a high enough clearance
meanwhile Edwards had come up with a
prototype for a machine that can mimic
scp-4051's abilities a few weeks after
it was approved science 17 had a minor
Containment Breach and a few hostile
anomalies overran armed Personnel Raynor
was present at the time and used his
wormholes to term the anomalies before
containment was re-established even
though he saved lives yazenia was forced
to reprimand him for using his powers
without authorization that he was banned
from any maintenance for two months
several months later the machine to
mimic raynor's Powers 350 Janus isn't
working correctly and keeps producing
the wrong object izenia keeps requesting
information on edwards's experiments but
is denied every time even when she asks
the Ethics Committee for a review on the
project the machine worked but only once
breaking right after
scp-4051 Story is a strange one it
involved an MTF Mission sent into a
dangerous area to contain an object with
Rainer sent along with them the full
mission log has yet to be Declassified
and maybe we'll cover it in a future
video but for now let's just say
something went wrong during that mission
the foundation discovered something new
and dangerous about
scp-4051's powers and a closer eye fell
upon the project the Ethics Committee
reevaluated what had gone on with
scp-4051 and the site director
surrendered information that Edward's
experiments hadn't been all in the name
of science that he might have been
needlessly cruel and violent to an
innocent anomaly just because he wanted
revenge for The Accidental mutilation of
his brother after taking a closer look
the Ethics Committee came to the
decision that scp-4051 needed to be
rethought large portions of the document
were redacted and classified and they
tried to bury the project
scp-4051's Powers were too dangerous to
allow about the site his permissions
were revoked and he was placed into
permanent containment in a more
specialized cell the researchers of the
foundation need oversight otherwise you
get incidents like scp-4051 where
eventual doctors subjected an otherwise
innocent being to brutal surgical
experiments and manipulation under the
guise of research it goes to show that
the foundation isn't always the good
good guy in fact from the perspective of
the anomalies the foundation can be
pretty damn evil hello again it's good
to have you back and yes we really do
mean you we're aware that you watch a
lot of these videos drinking in all that
classified information about some of the
SCP foundation's most top secret
anomalies you probably think you're
pretty slick don't you as if nobody
could see you peering in and even if
they could they wouldn't remember it
soon after yes you're a very clever
anomaly we wouldn't even think of
arguing against that that's why this
video is about you
scp-3393 don't be alarmed we're on the
same page here we know that you access
these files particularly the files
regarding yourself and your own
activities we know that you're on the
shy side and we definitely appreciate
that unlike our other Shy Guy you don't
brutally murder everyone who witnesses
you your greatest crime is accessing and
even tampering with SCP Foundation files
without permission but seeing as the
foundation is cold not cruel we can
think we can forgive that little
indiscretion of yours for the greater
good all we ask for is your attention
and a few minutes of your time you're a
vain creature who or whatever you are so
we know you wouldn't even resist the
opportunity to hear what we have to say
about you and for the record you are one
of the few people who are actually
witnessing this video in the way you're
witnessing it right now it's for your
eyes only so to speak
scp-3393 this video its description and
even the coding of its comments section
is filled with state-of-the-art memetic
agents cooked up by our best and
brightest to everyone except you the
researcher heading your case the head of
the anti-memetics division and a single
member of the o5 council this is just
your average run-of-the-mill video this
is a private conversation between you
and the foundation
scp-3393 we hope you don't mind the
designation it's not like we know your
real name but we can make some rather
educated guesses we actually know very
little about you on the whole a fact we
hope to change in the future much like
several other anomalies we have files on
such as scp-055 the self-keeping secret
and
scp-2256 the very tall things
information recorded about you isn't
exactly sustainable it becomes forgotten
or unreadable shortly after it's noted
down it's a clever anomalous ability and
one we've only been able to counteract
with the application of powerful
amnestic drugs but clearly that isn't
the only thing you have going for you
how do you think you've been able to
access all of these videos filled with
classified information about anomalies
groups of interest and even the inner
workings of the foundation itself
through methods currently unknown to us
you've been able to somehow give your
account level 4 clearance giving you
free Reign Over almost every file
available as much as it shames us to
admit it we haven't been able to remove
this unpermitted clearance from your
account or even located for that matter
like we've said before you're a very
clever anomaly we respect that about you
even though you've been using this
apparently crafty sapiens to
inconvenience us our best guess is that
you owe much of your success to powerful
anti-memetic properties inherent to your
anomalous being but if we're off the
mark on that do feel free to Enlighten
us speaking of guesses let's get back to
what we think we know about you after
all that's why you're really here isn't
it no point being bashful
scp-3393 you may be good at hiding
yourself but your intentions are plain
as day you don't need to be a senior
researcher here to Intuit that much
about you the fall following are all
facts we believe we know about you with
90 confidence you'll have to let us know
how close we were in the end assumption
number one you are a corporeal entity
that's right you probably wanted us to
assume that you were some kind of
digital ghost didn't you some mysterious
ethereal thought form existing only in
the realm of cyberspace while you sneak
around site 31 making Mischief we're
afraid that the ghost has been given up
so to speak as clever as you are it
isn't quite as clever as you believe
yourself to be you've gotten sloppy at
times and in these moments you've given
us a wealth of evidence don't you think
the foundation researchers and guards
people trained to notice even the most
minute anomalous interference wouldn't
notice doors opening and closing on
their own equipment moving computer
terminals activated despite no digital
trace of approved Foundation login
credentials we must say we're a little
insulted by how much you've
underestimated us here we know the files
you've accessed us we know that you're
aware of some of the monstrosities the
foundation deals with ghosts deadly
viruses reality warpers some creatures
that can shape-shift or become invisible
deadly memes for goodness sake did you
really think our Personnel would see the
signs of your meddling and think it was
probably nothing that's a rather
dangerous oversight on your part
assumption number two you're attracted
to information about yourself don't try
to deny this one scp-3393 the fact
you're still watching this video is
proof of yourself Obsession and you've
left your digital fingerprints all over
any other file that made the mistake of
mentioning you we have Pages upon pages
of log showing your long record of
unauthorized access and the grand
majority of the files you access were
about you like we said you're a vain
little creature that much is plain to
see this leads us nicely on to
assumption number three you seek out
this information about yourself in order
to make changes to it or even deleted
entirely if it displeases you we'll
admit this one we find the most
frustrating it's one thing to access
files without our permission quite
another to mess with our hard work we
get enough problems from technical
director Rosen already without needing
to constantly pester him about improving
file security the file about you has
undergone a number of needless
modifications and deletions the
following was a personal favorite quote
object class Euclid special containment
procedures don't worry I can handle this
description I wasn't supposed to happen
I wasn't supposed to exist at least not
like this but let me deal with it this
thing that I am is Best Kept away from
all of you don't try to analyze me or
test me or whatever I don't want any of
you to catch what I have just call me
self-containing and we'll be good end
quote we suppose you thought this one
was pretty funny right you're clearly an
intelligent creature who or whatever you
are but the clear arrogance on display
here doesn't suit you while you may
Coast off of your anti-memetic
properties it is important to remember
that you aren't Untouchable speaking of
which assumption number four your
anti-memetic properties can be
transferred we found this to be a
particular interesting Wrinkle In Your
Story we know you've got a sense of
humor so you'll have to appreciate the
irony in your attempts to alter or
destroy information about yourself
telling us more about you than we ever
knew before initially when other files
were reported missing we thought you
must have been deleting them out of
spite however upon further examination
we found that the files were still very
much there and you were the last user to
access them this is perhaps the most
dangerous thing about you and we don't
even know if you knew it until now your
anti-memetic properties have a tendency
to rub off and affect the things you
interact with with a power like that you
could compromise the whole database and
obviously we can't allow that to happen
assumption number five you have a strong
resistance to memetic agents much to our
frustration we know that they can affect
you of course but your tolerance is far
higher than that of the average human
being we needed to load this video with
some of our very best just to make sure
it would actually work your memetic
resistance has even foiled certain prior
containment attempts so you've really
been making us earn our keep
scp-3393 assumption number six you are
confined to site 31 this is another
Inconvenient Truth for you isn't it
first we need to figure out your
corporeal being existing out here in
space-time with the rest of us and then
we figure out exactly which space and
time you're occupying Can You Feel The
Net tightening around you 3393 of course
we don't want you to be nervous just sit
tight and enjoy the video you're a very
clever anomaly after all far too clever
to be contained by the likes of us
you've been performing your operations
right under the noses of site-31's most
talented Personnel all the phenomenon
we've been attributing to you from the
open doors to the tampered computer
terminals have occurred exclusively in
site-31 and while we may not be able to
track down your account and strip it of
its phony clearances did you know we can
log which computer terminals
unauthorized access to our files comes
from that's just basic cyber security
and we don't need to tell you that all
of your unauthorized accesses have been
logged to site-31 terminals very sloppy
3393 or should we call you Dr Mackie
forgive us if that isn't your name we
hate to jump to conclusions here at the
foundation but we couldn't help but
notice that your anomalous activity
began shortly after a researcher named
Dr Mackey disappeared from site-31
interestingly much like you Dr Mackey
isn't remembered by anyone else on the
site we only know Dr Mackey worked here
from records we discovered not too long
ago we we know that Dr Mackey was
conducting experiments here though data
on the particulars of those experiments
have been destroyed by you we presume we
also presume that you were most likely
either Dr Mackey or the product of one
of Dr mackie's experiments we've made a
few attempts to NAB you already but
you've always slipped through the cracks
like the sweep of site-31 where we sent
in mtf-810 see no evil our team that
specializes in combating visual Cognito
hazards those guys are tough cookies and
they're damn good at their job so it is
a mystery how you evaded them our
current best guess is that you were
hiding in some undocumented location
within the site our attempts at memetic
incapacitation were equally unsuccessful
as we mentioned before it's clear that
you have a greater resilience to memetic
agents than any of your non-anomalous
counterparts we estimate that even a
kill agent would probably do little more
than weaken you that is impressive we'll
give you that our estimation for why
you've been able able to so handedly
thwart our attempts at containing you is
that your access to the system has also
given you access to all of our plans you
know exactly what's going on before we
even execute the attempt giving you time
to think up and execute an effective
counter measure but we here at the
foundation believe that knowledge is
power
scp-3393 and we have more than enough to
finally contain You Don't Panic it's
already essentially over but will do you
the courtesy of explaining how we got
you in the end welcome to operation bait
the hook we know you're within sight 31
and we know you're attracted to
information about yourself so we limited
the scope of where this handy little
video could be viewed to five terminals
in the site we put measures in place to
notify us whenever the file was accessed
and from which terminal at which point
MTF 8 to 10 would be dispatched to seal
off all available exits and quarantine
the room around the terminal a process
that would only take several minutes
just enough time for a vain little
creature to watch a video about itself
as it's forever entombed within the
Telltale terminal that finally gave it
away you wouldn't be brought into a
containment chamber so we simply brought
the containment chamber to you as the
network connections for this particular
terminal are shut off we can safely say
you won't be causing us problems anymore
you're a very clever anomaly
scp-3393 just not quite as clever as us
a woman walks through the lonely Hills
in the dead of night her purple sorry is
torn and filthy from Days of exposure to
the elements her bare feet have been cut
up and bruised by the rough terrain she
walks but her clothes and feet are not
the most noticeable thing about her this
woman is pregnant her belly swollen two
freakish proportions it's frankly a
miracle that she's even able to walk in
this state she stumbles and sways under
the weight of the thing growing inside
her whatever it is it's too
to be any kind of ordinary baby but she
keeps moving muttering to herself in a
language that no human ear has heard in
years her eyes are glazed over almost
hypnotized she moves with great purpose
but her vacant facial expression makes
it appear as though she doesn't know
exactly what that purpose is she just
needs to keep moving further into the
Wilderness until it happens whatever it
is the one thing that's certain is that
it isn't anything good a car rumbles
down a nearby dirt road it's being
driven by Dr vinay ramachadran a medical
practitioner from the nearby city of
Surat who occasionally drives out to the
more rural areas where the locals might
not have easy access to medical help he
spots the Staggering woman and
immediately pumps the brakes of his car
she's clearly in need of medical
attention thank goodness he happened to
be driving by the time Dr ramashadharan
grabs his medical bag from the back seat
and rushes towards the woman who
collapses in
her that's when to his utter horror Dr
ramachataran notices that the woman's
belly is continuing to swell at an
unnatural rate even for a woman who is
heavily pregnant with triplets this
would still be far too large and the
rate at which she's swelling is akin to
someone blowing up a balloon by the time
Dr ramacharan reaches her the worst has
already happened the woman's belly has
burst open and crouching on her corpse
is the thing that was growing inside her
an adult man nude and covered in blood
Dr ramacharan's Terror only increases
when he notices that the man is eating
her elsewhere a riot is unfolding in the
streets a megaphone wielding instigator
barks orders for violence and Chaos as
the rioters spread setting fires
smashing windows and attacking any
unfortunate civilians caught in their
way it's one of the worst riots that the
area has ever seen even the veteran Riot
comps are frightened by the ferocity of
it the cops descend and clash with a
crowd of ever-advancing rioters they're
beaten back with crowbars baseball bats
knives and metal pipes and behind them
all the instigator continues spitting
his venomous words working the crowd
into an unmatchable frenzy they'll need
heavy reinforcements if they want to get
this Riot under control that's when one
of the riot cops on the front line
Sergeant Abhishek notices something
strange so many of the rioters seem to
have the exact same face the face of the
instigator Another Place Another Time
four men are digging up a grave and a
desolate old graveyard they work
tirelessly all moving in perfect
synchronicity they're only interrupted
when a group of heavily armed men
crashed the party and start firing on
them but these grave robbers are
prepared all of them draw revolvers like
a gang in an old western and begin
returning fire causing the men in
tactical gear to seek cover behind the
nearby tombstones while one of the Grave
robbers continues to fire the other
three scattered during the confusion
when his gun runs dry with that Telltale
click the men in tactical gear
immediately rise up and pin cushion him
with shot after shot of their assault
rifles he does the bullet dance like
Tony Montana and collapses to the ground
but when the gunman approached to
confirm the kill there's a horrifying
twist of fate swarms of horrible red
flies start pouring out of every bullet
wound swarming the attackers who Retreat
swatting away horrible little insects
but there's so many of them there's no
way to stop at least some of them from
crawling into their mouths here's an
interesting fact all of these
nightmarish incidents are connected in
the year 1969 a mysterious man was
arrested in hematnakar an area in the
Indian state of Gujarat this man had
been accused of inciting civil unrest
terrorizing and distressing the local
people he was later extradited to an
unknown location after the Indian
authorities received a request from a
mysterious organization known as yep you
guessed it the SCP Foundation who could
this man have possibly been to attract
such attention the authorities thought
it best not to question it they were
probably just glad to be rid of the
Troublemaker once and for all except
they weren't not by a long shot a few
years later in 1975 a group of four men
were discovered in a cemetery this time
in Ahmedabad another location in Gujarat
India for desecrating Graves this would
be strange and setting enough but what
really sent things to the next level of
weirdness was the discovery that these
four men were all the same man each one
was not only genetically identical to
one another but also to the man that had
been extradited in 1969. you'd be more
than justified in asking what the hell
is going on here maybe they were just a
group of Highly rare quintuplets five
children all born from the same mother
who just happened to have a predilection
towards crime and anti-social Behavior
or perhaps something stranger was afoot
the four who appeared in the cemetery
might have been clones of the original
Troublemaker in himnatagar as relatively
simple as those explanations would be
the truth was in fact far far weirder
than mad science or coincidentally
criminal quintuplets the four from the
cemetery had been ambushed by operatives
of the global occult Coalition another
shadowy organization fans of this
channel are likely to recognize the
Coalition or GOC is a group that views
itself as the police of the Paranormal
World using extremely advanced
technology to destroy Supernatural
entities and artifacts rather than
contain them they've been known to work
both alongside and against the SCP
Foundation both groups combine interest
in four genetically identical men in an
Indian graveyard seem to suggest there
was something Supernatural about their
origin one of the men had been killed by
the GOC while the remaining three were
taken into custody by the SCP Foundation
gotta love the power of teamwork but who
were these men where have they come from
and why do they share identical genes to
the first man from six years earlier
could there have been even more of them
well in the Years following the
foundation has been able to determine
that yes there are more of these
genetically identical individuals out
there across the more rural states of
India like Gujarat rajasatan Himachal
Pradesh Ariana Punjab Jammu and Kashmir
there may be over a thousand instances
of the same person collectively they are
known as
p2833 while their outward appearance can
vary somewhat instances of scp-2833 all
share the exact same genetic traits as
each other depending on the area they
are located in these anomalous people
can speak various languages and Regional
dialects including Hindi English
Gujarati dogiri kashmiri Punjabi Urdu
and even an outdated unknown language
that doesn't correspond with any known
modern dialect or language family each
scp-2833 also possesses the ability to
manipulate the organic matter of their
own body now we don't mean that these
men will stretch themselves like Mr
Fantastic or turn into something out of
John Carpenter's The Thing but they're
able to use their bodies to create
well something
scp-2833 instances can produce a small
anomalous parasite known as
scp-2833-a these are often released
through any bodily orifice like the
mouth nose or ears or through any Cuts
or open wounds suffered by an scp-2833
in other words if you shot and killed an
scp-2833 perhaps in a cemetery under the
orders of the global codes Coalition
then these parasites would still be able
to escape through the victim's bullet
wounds the only way to stop this from
happening is to incinerate the body of a
deceased scp-2833 burning them until
there is nothing left so what exactly
are these parasites well they're tiny
invertebrates meaning they're a small
cold-blooded organism with no spine that
can live on land or in water they
closely resemble diphtherians which are
any order of insects that contain what
we know as flies red in color and 20
millimeters in length
scp-2833-as are composed of combination
of muscle tissue keratin the protein
that your hair skin and fingernails are
made from and traces of Ash strangely
enough they are also capable of flying
with their two wings and will use these
to attempt to enter the body of a
suitable host while this can be any
vertebrate creature it seems they have a
preference for humans once inside the
host's body an
scp-2833-a parasite will attach itself
to their nervous system this then allows
the scp-2833 instance that the parasite
originated from to control the body of
the host taking over their bodily and
motor functions nervous system and all
of their sensory organs from here an
scp-2833 will then either subject the
target to Vivid inescapable
hallucinations or manipulate the
functions of their body the parasites
also contain a miniature instance of
another
scp-2833 only about two millimeters long
while these mini scp-2833s are usually
chemically inactive lying dormant and
unable to move this changes if the
parasite's host is a human female in
these cases the
scp-2833-8 creature will implant the
miniature scp-2833 within the uterus of
their female host after this the new
scp-2833 will begin to rapidly grow
consuming any and all organic matter
that surrounds it once again the
scp-2833 that the parasite originated
from is still able to manipulate the
female host's body and will use this
control to make her leave her home and
travel away from any Urban environment
after a year this new instance of
scp-2833 will be born in a truly
horrific fashion every time this happens
the female host is unable to survive the
process dying as a result of being used
as an incubator for the parasites the
newly formed scp-2833 will retain all
memories of the previous instance that
released the parasite they are even able
to speak fluently from the moment they
are born but that isn't the most
horrific part what happens next is that
the newborn scp-2833 will then Devour
the body of the female host that carried
it sometimes the host can die before an
scp-2833 is born with the parasite
keeping their body embalmed until the
new instance emerges but regardless the
mother of an scp-2833 will always die
during birth the SCP Foundation has
conducted a number of interviews with
the instances of scp-2833 that they have
captured and detained the first
scp-2833-1 the man causing civil unrest
in himatagar 1969 referred to himself as
we implying that all the scp-2833
instances share the same Consciousness
acting as a hive mind of sorts one of
the men from the cemetery
scp-2833-4 elaborated further on the
nature of these anomalous beings when
asked how many of the instances existed
we are in your cages we are distant from
the hordes of the ignorant we are grown
like crops and livestock we are growing
in numbers and faith and we will grow
until the Ascension of samadeh samadhir
is beyond side the buried will rise to
be exhumed as the doorway to rebirth
this is our cycle waiting for somebody
with patience we shall dance the tandava
and consume the world for its rebirth
samadhi is a word meaning a crypt
usually the final resting place of a
saint or someone of religious
significance Additionally the tandava is
an ancient dance that according to
Legends was performed by the Hindu god
Shiva who is believed to be the source
of all things the cycle of creation
preservation and destruction so these
anomalous beings and their parasites
appeared to be awaiting the discovery of
an ancient burial site where someone or
something was prophesied to rise consume
the world and then recreate it thinking
this Sunday might pose a threat the
foundation probe day later instance of
scp-2833 for further information on its
significance if you intend to seek some
of thee your quest is in vain for we are
the character to somebody only we
scp-2833-42 protested when asked about
the samadhi by a foundation researcher
one Dr Sanjay shiel samadhi does not
threaten it is we who were threatened
exiled when the colossality we are the
remnants and we are never defeated the
instance went on we are of Glorious
lineage The Chosen stock of karsis
vasque only the strongest and most
zealous may serve his purpose to that
end we consume ourselves to persist and
await for samadhi when asked who exactly
karstvsky was
scp-2833-42 answered we are we are
karsis Vasquez that word karsus has long
been associated with the religious Cult
of sarcasism another group of interests
you're likely to be familiar with if
you're a fan of what we do here this
group worships flesh and disease and is
seen as an apocalyptic threat by the SCP
Foundation the Sarkis religion was
founded thousands of years ago by an
ancient Elder being known as the
sorcerer king of aritam also called
Grand karcissist ion the goal of
sarkicism is to bring about a new age of
Flesh elevating Humanity to the form of
gods and potentially terraforming the
entire Earth using scp-610 the flesh
that hates so who or what was karstvasky
what role did it have in the religion of
sarcasism and how does it link to
scp-2833 the foundation has collected a
number of documents once belonging to a
man named Sir William Henry Sleeman
Sleeman was an administrator who worked
in India on behalf of the British East
India Company before his death in 1856
and it is in his documents that some of
the answers can be found according to
Sir William the poor of India told him
about a group of Mystics who were both
revered and feared among the country's
peasantry this group called themselves
the vatula seemed to hold what Sleeman
described as an unusual fetish towards
death and Decay sounds an awful lot like
the sarkists doesn't it Sir William
heard rumors that these vatula worshiped
Shiva but were never seen at temples
choosing instead to worship the Hindu
god in seclusion additionally though
each member of the vatula when asked
identified themselves by the title of
karsis vasque not everyone feared them
however as a group of men would often
attack them these men were thuggy
organized gangs of professional robbers
and murderers that traveled India
strangling their victims to death and
robbing them blind perhaps because of
this vatula seemed wary to interact with
any other worshipers of Shiva often
dismissing them as Pretenders to the
faith hoping to appease and gain an
audience with the vatula sir William's
allies Unleashed what they called the
daughter of Shadows better known as
scp-029 this divided the thuggy in the
hopes that the vatula would then accept
Suleiman as an ally eventually he
achieved an audience with them and was
unable to determine whether the group
was genuinely devoted to their religious
beliefs or was just a group of Mad Men
what Sir William didn't realize was that
under the Vestige of karstvasky this
group was subtly spreading the influence
of sarcasism over India as for scp-2833
perhaps they are the descendants of the
vatula group their lineage continuing
through the passing of those little
parasites it's highly likely that these
vatula were all early instances of
scp-2833 which would explain why those
captured by the SCP Foundation claim
that they are all karsus vasque a few
years back in 2014 one of the
foundation's mobile task forces
uncovered a body that was a genetic
match to the other instances of scp-2833
however this one wasn't found in India
but in krasneroskai Russia it had
strange growths on its muscle tissue and
Bones carrying multiple
scp-2833-a parasites inside its internal
organs the body had even been modified
to contain an artificial uterus which
carried an infant scp-2833 instance it
seemed that not only have scp-2833 found
a new way to evolve carrying themselves
in a modified body but they're also
beginning to spread further than ever
before you gotta hand it to the sarcasts
there's certainly adaptable what is your
favorite word think about it for a
moment think real hard write it down in
the comments posted for everyone else to
see how many letters does it have how
many syllables say it aloud how does it
sound how does it feel on your tongue
really really think about it now make
sure you keep that word in mind it's
important and we'll come back to it
later for now it's time to talk about
scp-3449 look there's really nothing any
special about this one it wasn't even
important enough to be mentioned with
the other info hazards it's not an evil
talking toaster that's for sure
scp-3449 appears to just be a standard
spiral notebook not book it's supposed
to be notebook right anyway it's just a
standard spiral notebook with a dark
blue cover it's safe class and it's
stored in the stand red
standard containment Locker in site 19.
there aren't any other containment
requires but testing is currently
underway to determined
um I think it's meant to be determined
long-term containment requirements ah
this is a mess anyway this item and its
anomalous power is actually considered
so inconsequential that researchers have
explored the possibility of putting it
on the anomalous items log a place where
items too useless to warn to full file
ends up geez how do you misspell up that
badly it's two letters false supposed to
be two letters how did you work Z into
that they aren't even close to each
other on keyboard
man anyway the notebook contains mostly
blank pages some are torn and only six
contain actual writing but due to the
formatting of the ridding the text
consisting mainly of diary entries is
almost unreadable this is due to
synaptical errors random capitalization
and rampant imp spellings great You
misspelled misspellings
how cute apparently all attempts to
correct these misspellings fail or even
lead to additional misspellings this
anomalous effect extends to anyone
attempting to write yep that was spelled
r-i-g-h-t anyone attempting to write
about
scp-3449 including the script for this
video apparently there are no further
notable Anonymous properties tests are
ongoing though those with any inquiries
about testing scp-3449 should contact
lead researcher Nicolo gerdinell The
Notebook which was misspelled even worse
this time impressive was first recovered
by MTF Epsilon 6 also known as The
Village idiots after a series of info
hazardous and Cognito hazardous
phenomenon were discovered in the
Pittsburgh Metroid area The Source
seemed to be a storage unit filled with
anomalous items and scp-3449 was a mogus
I think that's meant to be among them
the story unit was registered to a man
by the name of Edward salzbro currently
designated as porpoise of Interest 4335
that's the end of that thanks for
watching the video folks now go check
out oh wait there's more phenomenal
let's keep going apparently that version
of the file was an older one let's check
the next one and see if that's any more
useful oh oh oh my it appears that the
updates here are actually quite
extensive
okay let's give this another try
scp-3449 is a Euclid class SPC kept in
the humanid containment cells of site
19. items affected by it are kept in
standard store eggs lockers for safe
class anomalous objects at the same site
the primary reason for the shift is that
scp-3449 has changed its object of
designation it is no longer the spiral
notebook it is now a 34 year old
Caucasian man known as Edward salzbro
formerly known as Person of Interest
4335 he is believed to be the creator of
the not Bock as well as other objects
found in the storage looker in
Pittsburgh
Foundation Personnel are now trying to
locate and contain any other objects
created by Mr sellsberg though success
has been limited on this front that was
cute
scp-3449's analogous abilities manifest
onto both Edward himself and all the
objects created by Him ridding about him
or any of these objects will result in
synaptical errors arbitrary
capitalization and Rampart imp smellings
attempts to revise or correct the
writing will either fail to remove the
errors or create new errors it appears
that the anomalonymous effects of
scp-3449 proper are more severe than
that of the ones caused by his anomalous
objects MTF Epsilon 6 also known as The
Village idiots apprehended as cp3449 in
his apartment just outside of Pittsburgh
he appeared to be in an advanced state
of disorientation and dehydration
records collected by the mobile task
force found that Mr selberg had not left
his apartment in over 10 days which
would account for his dire health
conditions Salzburg did not communicate
with mambas of the mobile task force but
did not reset arrest and subsequent
containment either okay okay these
spellings are rough but I'm going to try
and power through I am a professional
and we're almost there the following is
the full lug of items obtained from
scp-3449 Storage look car that also
exhibit his anomalous effects The
Notebook as already discussed the pages
are either blank torn or illegible
salzberg's computer files saved on this
device include spreadsheets dealing
personal finances ideals for products
and an unfinished horror novel that is
almost unratable due to the poor quality
of its writing grocery list had only two
written items Booter was spelled with
only one t and medication which was
spelled medication a planner last entry
was dated two weeks before containment
and believed to contain reminders to
perform various chores however a mixture
of poor or handwriting and word choice
allows for other interpretations and
finally Mr salzberg's cell phone
Foundation researchers were also able to
collect the call logs in hopes of
further tracking salzburg's
pre-containment activities the last
three calls which were all made on the
same day two weeks before contentment
dialed different numbers only one of
which was in use the foundation made
contact with the receiver of said call
who had no knowledge of
scp-3449 and claimed that they did not
answer the call lead researcher Nick
Lowe gerdanell conduced the first in
interview with
scp-3449 shortly after his capture when
he entered the interview chambri he
found that
scp-3449 was just sitting in the corner
which with his had in his hands rocking
back and forth in what appeared to be
apparent distress he then begun looking
down into his lap in twiddling his
thumbs like a child Nick Lowe engaged
him in a calm and polite tone addressing
him as
scp-3449 the autumnly made eye contact
with Dr gerdinell but he didn't respond
and instead continues starring at him as
guernanell axed further Quest Tunes
Salzburg simply didn't answer or would
at the very most acknowledge the
questions with simple gestures girdnell
asked whether Salzburg was making
products for his business to which he
smiled and shook his head gurnell then
asked Salzburg whether he could speak or
not or if it was merely a choose on his
part unsurprisingly Salzburg offered no
explanation and the interview came to a
close shortly afterwards tests are still
ongoing to find out if salzburg's
inability to spack or communicate come
as a result of his anomalous traits or
if this is simply a result of epiphonia
a uncommon but non-anomalous condition
that renders its victims unable to Spike
tests have confirmed that sellsburg does
have all the organs required for
vocalization but s appears to not use
them for the tests are required alright
there we have it that was a complete
nightmare to read thanks to
scp-3449's anomalous effects but at
least it's over now
go check out wait there's more
another update to the file good okay
all right let's go take a look oh I see
this is a lot more dangerous than I
thought I suppose I better read on
scp-3449 Hayes Ben upgraded to ketter
class anomal
scp-3449-a the new designation for
Edward salzburger is to be kept in a
high security Hazmat containment in site
19. the inanimate anomalous possessions
of Edward Salzburg are to be keeped in
standard object containment any reports
written on scp-3449 must be rotten by
Popple who have been exposed to it for
less than seven days in order to keep
the files raidable to prevent this
infectious info hasmart from spread
further the number of people allowed to
interact with this anomaly is kept
relatively small and consists of those
that have already been exposed at some
point or another this includes 05-8 MTF
Epsilon 6. Dr teller's research team
some additional Personnel selected for
xpc-3449 research and Personnel chosen
to update
scp-3449 documentation some additional
Personnel selected for xpc 3449 research
and Personnel chosen to update
scp-3449 documentation while Edward
sellsberg and his personal effects are
crudily locked up
scp-3449 is not currently considered
contained Research into the sprod of
scp-3449's effects the vectors for
transmission and any potential
recremities for its degenerative effects
are now taupe priority for all in love
before this whole thing gets out of hand
further research has taught the
foundation that not only are Salzburg
and his items powerful info hazards
their enemalis effects appear to be able
to infect these who experience them
permanently initially it will a prayer
that writing quality only degrades when
the subject is actually writing about
scp-3449 itself but over time they'll
come to the frightening realization that
it actually affects their riffing as a
whole the effect also progresses in its
similarity over time eventually
rendering the victim's ability to write
legible sentences completely displayed
the initial anomalous effects of
scp-3449 were discovered when MTF
Epsilon 6 writes their field reports on
the Mater and found it littered with
synaptical error random capitalization
and rampant in plillings similar errors
appearing in the initial fail about
scp-3449 only serve to reaffirm this
observation however researcher only
began to notice true extent of
scp-3449 effects when the village idiots
field reports concerning other
solomonies came in with equally
atrocious writing attempts to correct
this writing simply led to more
mustaches and frustration on part of
Team soon after a Reese stretcher named
Dr Teller who'd since track and ove were
the
scp-3449 case and his team found that
they were experienced to timbler issues
they couldn't just make the blurreds
happen no matter how hard they
constraint traded they forgot spellings
they couldn't make hand move in the
manner they waited to in order to form
the wards even the most intelligent and
articulate members of the team came
across as extremely young children on
page but didn't stop there wasn't long
before researchers who'd never worked on
the
scp-3449k started to exhibit these same
suspicious errors in own writing the
foundation didn't know how but this
through likeness was starting to spread
with people's abilities to write
degrading across the entire Foundation
that's when a foundation web trawler
picked up same thing even more
distrobbing Global literacies seemed to
be taking a dive The Telltale synaptical
error random to capitalization and
rampant illing misspellings tickling up
everywhere and for everyone and the end
of writing would be one thing but
scp-3449 doesn't stop there now that's
just the beginning Morse code go next
then pictograms not long for sign
language become hopeless scrambled
communication
breaks down little by little people
can't draw anymore can't move right
hands Gall goes calls codes last go his
voice talking gets her remember fabric
word
think about it say it loud when
scp-3449 done when everyone infected
you'll never say again nobody will ever
say again yeah
foreign
urban legends ghost stories or just full
Yarns the fact is we've all heard at
least one traditionally stories like
that were just shared around a campfire
but nowadays they have ended up
spreading far and wide across internet
message boards and creepy threads
everything ranging from unsolved missing
persons cases actually being the result
of alien abductions to haunted videos
carrying an unforgiving curse or some
missing unaired episode of popular TV
shows that had somehow been Unearthed by
an online sleuth we're always quick to
share these ideas these stories but deep
down a part of us knows that there's no
truth to them Urban myths are
speculation that someone has turned into
A Tale of Terror for nothing more than
to give some quick scares to whoever
they tell it to but then that person
passes that tail on to someone else then
suddenly the story had become a
widespread Legend with no discernible
point of origin sure they might still be
fictional but through sharing these
stories we as humans bring them to life
not literally of course that would be
outlandish after all when was the last
time you heard of a fictional story
becoming reality growing up with
exposure and unfiltered access to the
internet in the late 2000s Paul Jacobs
and his friends had been fascinated with
and admittedly pretty terrified by the
notorious legend of the Slenderman it
began as whisperings in an online Forum
a story that was intentionally designed
to be a modern day Urban myth and just
like so many others before it the myths
spread what had started as a forum post
became unnerving photoshopped images of
a tall faceless figure in a suit lurking
in the woods next an indie video game
and even a real world tragedy given how
young he was at the time still being in
high school Paul and a few others had
bought into the Slenderman myth
wholesale he believed it to be real this
towering expressionless Boogeyman the
more he learned about this malevolent
creature every story blog post or creepy
YouTube video made about Slenderman only
added more and more to his Legend and
kept young Paul awake at night afraid
that every noise outside his bedroom
window was the faceless horror of course
if you take away that belief the
possibility an urban legend might be
true then it simply loses its power it's
that potential that maybe Towing the
line between fantasy and reality that
can allow these stories to go on and
incite fear forever but that wasn't the
case for the Slenderman story and The
Craze for it quickly died down after it
was debunked numerous times over casting
it permanently back into the realm of
fiction but the profound effect the
legend had on Paul at a young age ended
up informing his future as he Grew Older
his past fear of certain stories be
became a keen interest in how these
Tales could influence people could any
story have that same impact or only
those that walked the line between
fictional and maybe being true did these
urban legends become more real to people
because of their subject matter or did
human beings give them that power to
transcend the constraints of fiction
just by believing in them as Paul got
older he began to study the truth behind
certain urban legends attempting to
trace them back to their Origins some
were often inspired by real events but
with specific details that had gradually
been altered from the original story the
more and more people passed it around
ghost stories seemed to be the most
changeable but with some roots in the
real world a person might have died a
hundred years ago and the story of them
haunting their old home or final resting
place would start to circulate then
shortly after another similar story
might emerge and the two would overlap
whoever was telling each story might
have added or omitted certain details or
combined elements of more than one tale
until what was left being passed around
was neither the first story nor the
second but a hybrid of different
versions from different storytellers
there was one legend that Paul felt
drawn to more than others and it was a
rather obscure one to say the least
during his self-conducted research into
stories of this nature he learned about
a tale that told of an ancient sect
called the davites according to Legends
some that dated so far back that they
preceded almost all of recorded history
these daveites were a callous and cruel
civilization they had emerged from a
book so the story went and sought only
to wage war on other cultures and
enslave their enemies but Paul also
uncovered one detail of the story that
intrigued him more than any other it
referred to something known as the
Eternal text and was regarded as some
kind of deity or figure of worship by
the daveites the legend stated that this
text had helped create the book that
they had emerged from of course this all
sounded like highly fictitious nonsense
to Paul Jacobs he knew that things of
such nature didn't exist in the real
world they were only part of stories but
he had noticed that this particular
story seemed to have passed its way
through the ages searching further Paul
had uncovered The Works of an obscure
author from the United States who had
only a few works that were known about
during the 1940s and 50s even then most
of his stories weren't widely published
only a few shorter pieces making it into
a magazine that had long since stopped
being printed this writer had died in
1957 having never seen his career in
fiction come to fruition but despite his
short-lived career and being considered
a somewhat subpar author at the time the
writer's work had garnered its own
little cult following online mostly
comprised of amateur authors it was
through them that Paul managed to obtain
some scanned copies of the Anonymous
writers stories particularly some that
he felt were a striking similarity to
the David Legends of the Eternal text
one story in particular written in a
style lifted directly from H.P Lovecraft
was based on a supposed encounter the
writer claimed to have had with
something that closely resembled the
Eternal text Paul also studied the
writer's own personal journals that he
had managed to recover scans of the
entries from it seemed to imply that the
author came across what he called the
written God and that this compelled him
to write a fictitional version of those
events it was only after writing about
this new encounter that what he had
depicted in his story seemed to come
true exactly as he'd written them this
led to a recursive process of the writer
creating these encounters only for them
to occur thus causing him to write about
it and then make it happen the entire
Prospect not only confused and
bewildered Paul but intrigued him
further as well although he had no way
of confirm firming what this writer had
claimed was true Paul believed that on a
smaller scale the author had achieved
the same effect that occurs during the
passing down of urban legends but the
difference here was that it had all been
done through himself via a singular
person telling variations on the same
story allowing it to continue and
perpetrate recursively of course Paul
didn't actually believe in this written
God or Eternal text those were all just
part of the fiction but he wanted to
experiment further and see if he could
achieve the same process for himself
taking an empty notebook Paul started to
write the first things that came to mind
basing a short story off of the
anonymous author's own tale he
intentionally changed a few key details
noting down things that weren't in the
original the written God appeared behind
me he wrote adding on a whim the line it
had no face the whole intention of
Paul's experiment was to pass his new
version of the story onto someone else
and then try to get them to write it
from memory he wanted to observe if
their mind would change certain details
subconsciously or if they would
misremember elements when they retold
their new version if enough people could
spread the story around each time
altering or adding new parts to it what
effect could it have as he finished his
Rewritten version of the author's tale
attaching it to an email to send to one
of his fellow writers Paul was
blissfully unaware of just what he'd
done a heavy knocking rang out
somebody's fist pounding at the front
door loud enough to wake him bleary-eyed
Paul checked the alarm clock next to his
bed it was the middle of the night
stumbling out of bed he staggered his
way towards the repetitive noise unsure
who or what would be calling the Slate
Paul froze for a second casting his mind
back to the story he had written earlier
surely not it couldn't be right it was
just a story after all but the author he
had described how how the things he'd
written had come true there it was that
possibility that maybe what if it was
behind the door right now suddenly
something much heavier than a hand
bashed against the wooden surface of the
front door causing it to fly open the
catch of the lock being ripped out of
the wall by the force of the impact a
group of black-clad figures rushed in
one of them tackling Paul to the ground
before he could even process what was
happening the weight of another person
pinned him down and kept him from moving
despite his attempts at struggling free
then the feeling of something sharped
poked at the Exposed Skin of Paul's neck
a needle filled with he wasn't sure all
he really knew right now was how dizzy
he was unable to stop himself from
slipping away the sedative quickly put
Paul back to sleep as the agents filed
into his home the floor he woke up on
was freezing cold blinking his heavy
eyelids until they opened again Paul did
his best to stand his head was still
spinning making it hard to keep his feet
still and to make matters worse the room
around him was hardly lit only a few low
fluorescents dimly illuminated the tiny
Space Mr Jacobs a voice boomed over a
crackly intercom the pitch lowered to
distort it further we need you to answer
a few questions for us what corresponded
in confusion where did you first learn
about
scp-582 the voice questioned barely
giving Paul a moment to think about what
what's an SCP he asked back he wrote a
story earlier today correct boomed the
Unseen speaker meekly Paul nodded his
head we wanted our online activity for
any mentions of scp-582 or anything
using any of its known aliases you mean
that written God Eternal text thing Paul
replied catching on to what the voice
had been referring to I read about it in
some stories by this old author he died
ages ago most of his work is pretty
Niche it's actually hard to track down
enough The Voice interjected bluntly
when did you specify scp-582 would
manifest manifest erased an eyebrow
confused again it was just a story
that's what I was doing I was examining
stories and how they change when they
get passed on Mr Jacobs it sounded as
though the voice had shifted still
distorted but now calmer more collected
somebody else was speaking it is
important to answer our questions your
life could be very well and
now do you remember when you wrote that
scp-582 when it going to appear what do
you mean in danger Paul retorted in a
panic what the heck even are you people
he looked down to see his hands were
trembling suddenly aware of the sweat
coating his forehead Paul took a series
of deep breaths trying to collect
himself I
I don't remember his side his voice now
shaking as much as the rest of him was
that a location The Voice pressed him
can you tell us where it's going to
appear I didn't write a location either
Paul answered I I just said it appeared
the words he had written earlier quickly
Came Crashing back into his head almost
like an urgent warning behind me as he
spoke Paul could sense someone standing
near him that same sensation you get
when you know another person is in the
room even when you haven't looked
directly at them yet Paul tried to keep
his head forward only tilting it
slightly to the side seeing something
dark looming just behind his shoulder he
couldn't rationalize any of what was
happening he was too scared to turn all
the way around doing that would admitted
all of this was real and not just some
horrific nightmare not just a story
for the first time the voice over the
intercom sounded uneasy
telling himself he'd wake up any second
Paul rotated with his eyes screwed shut
snapping them open once he was facing
nothing a blank space lacking any
expression and all the normal features
was looming over him with an empty
eyeless stare it had no face just like
in Paul's story he opened his mouth to
let out a scream only for it to be
interrupted by the crunching sounds of
neck bones twisting the wrong way as
Paul's lifeless body dropped back down
to the cold floor
scp-582 vanished just as quickly as it
had arrived the thing about some
anomalies is you have to be very careful
about how you talk about them not just
because they could be listening in and
might hear you but because what you say
about them might just have a nasty habit
of coming true that is the case with
scp-582 otherwise known as its rather
apt nickname a bundle of stories what's
so fitting about that title is its
accuracy that's all As
e582 really is stories but therein lies
it's true power this entity has a way of
propagating and perpetrating itself
continuously adapting and spreading like
a mutating virus except it doesn't pass
from person to person as an illness
there are no symptoms it transmits via
stories
scp-582 is a subject to a process of
passive reality manipulation it doesn't
necessarily directly change the world
around it but can itself be changed by
certain factors what this means is
anything said or written about this
entity even if pulled out of thin air a
fictional account of its Deeds all
becomes real let's say for example you
told a story about scp-582 sneaking up
behind a foundation researcher when his
back was turned telling that story would
cause those exact events to be carried
out in the real world when scp-582
manifests it will do so in accordance
with any details given in a fictional
account about it the same time the same
place on Earth it would appear in the
exact form that the tale specified if
any of those details were omitted or
purposely left vague then the entity
would still be able to manifest and
would do so in a way that fits the rest
of the narrative appearing wherever and
whenever it has an opportunity to as far
as the researchers at the SCP Foundation
can tell the actual abilities of scp-582
are usually left vague when people write
about it one of the few consistencies is
that the entity can disappear and
reappear at will to any place or time
another is that no method of harming or
even killing scp-582 has ever worked
even if written down as fiction in order
to be made fact and the other details or
abilities that someone assigns to the
creature will however become a permanent
addition to its growing myth meaning it
is able to perpetually increase increase
its power the more people write about it
on the rare occasion multiple different
writers accounts of scp-582 contradict
each other or don't fit into the
entity's own Canon it can easily adapt
to these contradictions this usually
results in conflicting information
having no effect on the bundle of
stories or having so little impact that
it is almost like they didn't happen at
all in short if one author's story
doesn't quite match up with another's
then the effect these additions have to
scp-582 and its ongoing story are
lessened so that they can all either
logically occur or be negated completely
it is because of this adaptability and
that it has been described by multiple
sources that portrayals of scp-582 tend
to be generalized this even extends down
to its appearance it's currently unknown
what the entity's true form is or if it
even has one However the fact that it is
usually depicted as a deity or God means
that this this bundle of stories has
been known to manifest as one of several
avatars the most common of these
appearances is that of a humanoid being
standing well over six feet tall when
manifesting as this particular form
scp-582 is dressed in thickly layered
robes made from burlap or Hessian
complete with a hood however no face is
visible underneath the creature's hood
and when presenting as this Avatar it is
often described as carrying sacks of
unknown contents sometimes even
appearing to bleed heavily there have
been a number of other incarnations of
scp-582 including a six-legged form that
is made out of pure molten tar and will
attack any nearby human beings on site
this Avatar would normally appear as
being fused with the first in other
instances it has appeared as a plant
capable of producing both light and
enough radiation to kill anyone in its
radius within a few hours of exposure
other times it has been a vaguely
human-shaped Shadow and even has one
form that exists within more than three
dimensions due to this form existing on
higher Dimensions this made it
impossible to properly perceive it with
the naked eye and resulted in the depths
of anyone who even looked partially at
it who knows maybe at some point it has
even been described as a tall slender
figure in a dark suit with pale skin and
a face with its eyes ears nose and mouth
all missing actually it's probably best
that nobody writes it down we don't want
it becoming real now do we the question
is how can you hope to contain or even
fight something that can be anything
anywhere and have any strength that
someone claims it has well just to be on
the safe side the foundation uses its
own fictional narrative to keep the
entity contained it is their hope that
by describing it as powerless it will
turn the creature's own reality altering
properties against it and actually cause
scp-582 to lose its ability
what thoughts if any that flow through
that alien mine are not mine to know it
remains silent and still within its
chamber entrenched in the Persistence of
its own memory it remains but only as a
shade of what it was its power spent
where at least come to rest so remember
scp-582 possesses no actual
Consciousness or free will anything it
has ever said or done is because someone
wrote that it would and yes we're only
saying that because we don't want to
write that it's broken free from
containment and is currently standing
behind you if we did that it might just
come true the SCP Foundation is
responsible for containing some of the
most dangerous forces in the world
without them we'd be at the mercy of the
plague doctor walking through the world
and killing with a touch anyone could be
snapped up by scp-106 and dragged to a
painful death in his pocket Dimension
layer there would be no one to stop
scp-682 from devouring all living things
in sight and no one to hold back the
dreaded Scarlet King from breaching our
world and destroying Life as we know it
we owe them a lot for sure and they've
earned at least a thank you card and an
Edible Arrangement but containing the
anomalies of the world comes at a pretty
steep cost they're essentially fighting
a war against a whole host of
world-ending entities and when you're at
War there are bound to be casualties for
some people and creatures out there the
most terrifying monster isn't 096 just
trying to swallow them whole for looking
at its face or 173 just waiting for them
to turn their back so it can snap their
neck for the unfortunates that find
themselves in the wrong place at the
wrong time the scariest monster in the
world is the SCP Foundation itself a
decade ago the SCP Foundation was
attempting to recapture scp-682 which
had breached containment and was tearing
its way through the southern Congo
region unable to contain the monster by
other means and desperate to stop it
from killing any more civilians the
foundation decided to implement some
rather Extreme Measures they deployed a
variety of chemical agents and poisonous
gases in an attempt to slow the creature
down but they had no effect as the
enormous reptile stomped its way toward
a nearby River with a highly populated
Village waiting on the other side the
foundation made the decision to take
things up a notch they launched an
aerial strike deploying several
aircrafts to drop explosives on the area
around the river they destroyed large
portions of the riverbank but the
environmental impact was considered to
be a necessary evil When the Smoke
finally cleared and the deafening Roars
of the Beast had gone quiet they stopped
their bombing campaign and dispatched
Foundation operatives to the scene there
they found the bones of scp-682 which
were quickly brought into custody before
the creature could begin to heal itself
the mission was considered a success and
they were ready to pull out all of their
staff and head back to the nearest
Foundation site when one officer spotted
something floating in the nearby River
it looked like a group of human corpses
face down in the water their bodies
badly burned concerned that civilians
from a nearby Village had been
inadvertently present for the bombing
campaign a team of officers was sent to
investigate the river more closely what
they found was not a group of dead
humans but something else entirely they
were all along the riverbank and
floating in the water approximately 212
specimens of a previously unknown
humanoid species the bodies were
clustered in groups of three to five
appearing to belong to the same family
unit or social group many of them were
frozen in positions of fear or attempt
to defend themselves with some observing
Personnel comparing them to the victims
of the Pompeii eruption stuck in their
final terrified moments what appeared to
be parents and children held on to each
other some covered their faces others
lay in a fetal position it seemed that
they had known something was coming to
kill them but they did not have the time
or the understanding necessary to escape
it several of the bodies were removed
from the river for autopsy and
examination in order to understand more
about this new possibly already extinct
species they were humanoid organisms
with an indeterminable genus and species
they resembled tall thin humans with
absolutely no body hair and elongated
limbs the most unusual aspect of the
creatures was in their mouths their
teeth were serrated and sharp resembling
those of a crocodile in spite of these
monstrous teeth an autopsy revealed that
there was no human flesh present in any
of the creature's stomachs instead
suggesting a diet of fish livestock and
whatever else they could peacefully
scavenge every last corpse was removed
from the area and incinerated to prevent
any civilians from coming across them
and asking questions just when the
foundation person now we're finally
packing up and getting ready to leave
the river once and for all they heard
something it was a mournful sound
something between a man bellowing and a
wild animal yelping in pain something
nearby was still very much alive and it
was screaming the officers followed this
sound and spotted one surviving specimen
of the crocodile people lying along the
bank of the river it was holding its
face in its hands curled up into a ball
near the water and it was wailing in
agony there were no visible injuries on
the creature's body but it was clearly
extremely distressed one officer
attempted to approach the creature
calling out to it that he meant no harm
and wanted to get it some medical
attention and looked up at the officer
with wide eyes and its cries went quiet
the officer grabbed his weapon afraid
that the creature might suddenly Rush
him but instead it ran into the river he
jumped into the water plunging beneath
the surface and began thrashing around
at after a moment of watching its
struggle the officer realized what was
happening the creature was trying to
drown itself the abandoned protocol
completely at that moment diving into
the water and pulling the struggling
creature back to shore it coughed up
water for several minutes all the while
trying to crawl back into the water when
the creature had finally calmed down it
was brought into Foundation custody with
no further resistance it appeared to be
the last Living member of whatever
strange human crocodile hybrid species
was living in that River and it was
designated as CP 6415 since it was
brought into Foundation custody
scp-6415's Behavior has been largely
very consistent some scps are constantly
attempting to escape from their
containment or killing an endless
revolving door of d-class personnel but
6415 is not one of those anomalies it is
not aggressive in spite of its
crocodilian characteristics and it's
content to eat the food provided by the
foundation it is fed a diet of raw meat
mostly beef and goat which is provided
fresh daily the foundation was curious
to see if the creature could be pushed
to be aggressive if its circumstances
were made a little less comfortable they
deprived it of food for several days but
it did not seem to notice or even care
much aside from occasionally looking at
the door to see if new food had come
they tried sleep deprivation next
blaring a loud siren sound over the
speakers in the containment chamber
anytime the creature was observed lying
down or closing its eyes it became
listless and visibly exhausted but did
not act out violently at this either
after this testing its ordinary feeding
and sleep schedule was resumed for the
most part all that
scp-6415 does is eat and sleep there is
however one notable exception at random
intervals
scp-6415 will begin to cry sobbing
intensely and appearing to be in a state
of overwhelming distress its cries are
so loud that they can be heard from
several Halls away and have caused
hearing damage and Personnel in the room
with it there is no way to stop the
Creature From Crying once it has started
though providing it with a hot cup of
tea a soft blanket or a hug from a
particularly Brave and eager d-class has
caused it to cry a bit more quietly once
it is finished crying after several
hours of non-stop weeping it'll lie down
on the ground and not cry anymore for
weeks at a time for a time
scp-6415 was considered to be lacking
human intelligence and its containment
procedures were changed to reflect that
it was held in the standard humanoid
containment chamber in the light
containment wing of site 619 with
soundproof walls because it displayed no
threatening behavior it was considered
unnecessary to have any guards placed
outside 6415s chamber however after
incident
6415-01 the foundation's understanding
of the creature changed dramatically the
incident occurred when several d-class
Personnel were sent into 6415's
containment chamber to feed it and they
found a harrowing sight on the wall of
the chamber The Entity had scratched a
message with its fingernails its
fingertips were bloodied and torn its
hands noticeably wounded from what must
have been a great deal of effort it did
not acknowledge the Personnel that
entered the room instead it just sat on
the floor staring at its work on the
wall cradling its injured hands and
crying its shoulders shook with the
force of its sobs and its tears fell to
the ground pooling around it the d-class
Personnel were later unable to report
what they had seen without beginning to
cry themselves but eventually calmed
down enough to report what the creature
had written please bring them back it
was a desperate plea for the foundation
to somehow reunite it with its lost
family they had previously thought the
creature to be a simple animal incapable
of understanding its own reality or
communicating through clear language
this proved that the creature understood
very well what had happened to it and
was feeling the loss of its loved ones
fully one d-class officer noticed a
scrap of paper likely a piece of butcher
paper from one of the creature's
previous meals with a picture drawn on
it it was a crude sketch but its subject
was easily recognizable it was the
southern Congo River where 6415 was
first discovered with three creatures
splashing in the water the largest one
resembled as cp6415 and it was swimming
alongside a slightly smaller adult of
its species and a much smaller creature
that appeared to be a juvenile of the
same species context clues indicated
that this was a drawing of
scp-6415's family its partner and their
child at first the foundation
researchers were uncertain who exactly
the creature was referring to in its
initial message but this drawing made it
perfectly clear it wanted its family
back it is uncertain whether or not the
creature is aware that its family is
dead but it clearly feels their absence
just the same and believes the
foundation might have the power to end
its suffering Foundation Personnel who
were exposed to the details of the
incident became inconsolable falling
into a deep bout of depression brought
on by a sense of Shame and
responsibility when counseling sessions
proved ineffective the emotionally
affected staff were given amnestics to
wipe their memory of the incident and of
6415 altogether one employee research
assistant Cheryl Cruz attempted to
release the creature from its
containment insisting that it deserved
to roam free however when she opened the
door to its containment facility the
creature made no move to leave it just
stared at her tears in its eyes as if it
knew that it had nowhere else to go
research assistant Crews was given a
powerful amnestic and relieved of her
position at the foundation her current
whereabouts are unknown in order to
prevent any more Reckless Behavior from
sympathetic staff the message scratched
into the wall was paid painted over and
the sketch recovered from its chamber
was destroyed but even if the memories
and evidence of the creature's pain are
gone anyone walking by its chamber can
still hear it weeping it is uncertain
what the containment procedures for
scp-6415 will become it is not simply an
animal and clearly understands language
though it appears to be incapable of
speech if it could talk whatever it said
would surely be heartbreaking for now
the entity remains in itself serving as
a grim reminder of the guilt that weighs
on the foundation's conscience no matter
what they do with 6415 they cannot take
back what they did they cannot lift the
weight of the creature's grief or bring
back its lost family it is the Lone
Survivor sitting in its foundation cell
weeping for its broken heart and begging
the foundation for the one thing it can
never do bring them back help me with
somebody please help me I'm lost and I
can't see it echoed through the alley in
a thin Reedy voice that suggested
brittleness of body and spirit who
wouldn't hear that cry and feel a Pang
of sympathy are you so heartless that
you'd ignore the desperate pleas for
help of a blind man clearly in distress
for all you know he might even be in
danger what if he walks into a road and
gets hit by a car would you really want
that on your conscience questions like
these were flying through the head of
the Good Samaritan when he decided to go
and investigate when it seemed like
everyone else was just content to
pretend they didn't hear it and carry on
with their day as normal the Good
Samaritan was a person not unlike
yourself they were also the kind of
person we all hoped and wished we would
be in a situation such as this kindness
and generosity is a virtue after all the
problem is there are people out there
who know this and are willing to take
advantage of that kindness and
generosity but even worse is the fact
that there are things that are
definitely not people out there willing
to take advantage of human compassion
too but back to the Good Samaritan he
approached the sound of the distressed
man in the alley he looked old and frail
hunched over with the weight of his ears
he wore thick dark glasses and his white
cane was laying on the road a few feet
away from him it was a tragic scene but
thankfully the Good Samaritan was here
to help he approached the old man calmly
telling him that it would be okay the
Good Samaritan picked up the walking
cane and passed it over to the blind old
man his face spread into a warm smile
and he said thank you thank you thank
you young man
it warms my heart to know there are
still good people like you on this Earth
the old man told the Good Samaritan that
he'd come into town to get some fresh
air and a little exercise at which point
he'd gotten lost when the Good Samaritan
asked whether it was safe for him to
come alone the old man told him that he
always used to go on walks with his wife
but ever since the accident she didn't
seem to want to be seen in public the
Good Samaritan naturally felt for the
old man who seemed as sweet as he was
feeble he offered to escort the old man
back to his house personally wanting to
make sure that he returned home safely
the old man smiled and graciously
accepted saying that his wife would
probably want to thank the kind young
man for helping him in person of course
the Good Samaritan was so wrapped up in
the warm glow of doing a good deed that
he never once stopped to question the
strangeness of this whole situation he
just walked along with the old man
listening to him tell his fanciful
stories as they left the city center and
crept further into the Sleepy outskirts
of their small Kentucky Town it was just
rambling on as old men tend to do he
told the Good Samaritan a little more
about his beloved wife she was a kind
woman who'd he'd known for as long as he
could remember his elementary school
sweetheart then his high school
girlfriend and not long after they
graduated his beautiful Blushing Bride
oh yes she'd always been the prettiest
lady until the accident curiosity was
getting the better of him the Good
Samaritan couldn't help but ask what
exactly the accident he kept alluding to
was and the old man was all too happy to
give him an answer not that this answer
was in any way Pleasant his wife had
been trapped in a terrible fire in town
that gave her severe burns all over her
body she was lucky to be alive but the
Flames took her beauty and her
confidence away from her since then
she'd become a real homebody often
refusing to leave the house and rarely
ever letting strangers see her the good
Samaritan's heart ached for this poor
old couple why were such nice people
often forced to endure so much suffering
did this old man even have anyone else
to talk to they reached his house soon
enough it was the furthest one on the
end of the street right next to the
darkness of the woods it looked old and
dilapidated but it wasn't like the old
blind man could even know that as they
were walking up the small set of stairs
to the porch the old man stumbled
slightly causing his thick dark glasses
to fall to the floor the Good Samaritan
reflexively leaned over to pick up the
glasses for the old man as he passed
them back he noticed something strange
the old man wasn't just blind he
literally didn't have any eyes just two
black empty sockets where his eyes
should be the Good Samaritan was just
thankful that the old man wasn't able to
see him staring as he put the glasses
back on the two of them entered the
house the Good Samaritan was too busy
thinking about the old man's empty eye
sockets to even notice him locking the
door behind them and by then then it was
already too late for him the old man
called out into the dark expanse of the
house sweetheart I've got your live
world
for the Good Samaritan could ask what he
actually meant by that the old man
shuffled off definitely navigating the
Halls through memory alone and took one
of the two seats at the dining table he
just sat there smiling waiting that's
when the Good Samaritan heard the
creaking sound coming from above
something moving up in the darkness of
the second floor and then descending the
stairs with heavy clumping footsteps
when his eyes came into focus in the
dark he saw it there the most terrifying
thing he'd ever witnessed coming down
the stairs towards him it was vaguely
human in its shape alone but in all
other respects it was a monster through
and through this gnarled Twisted
creature with bulging eyes dead flesh
and filthy exposed fangs like it stepped
straight out of a nightmare and into the
physical world where it did not belong
there looked to be a huge hole in its
lower torso too with no blood or organs
inside just an infinite blackness the
creature's lipless mouth Twisted into a
smile the creature said something in a
voice that the Good Samaritan couldn't
understand it was the black tongue
something ancient terrifying and unknown
as the creature got closer and closer
the Good Samaritan turned and made a run
for the door he tried to figure out the
lock his hands fumbling and
uncoordinated by fear he could hear the
footsteps and the heavy breathing of
that thing getting closer behind him he
was so close almost there that's when a
strange black substance seemed to encase
the world around him it separated him
from the door he was so nearly able to
breach locking him in he was trapped
inside what looked like a giant black
sphere made of some unknown material or
energy he turned to see that monster
standing right behind him just grinning
and waiting for the inevitability of the
situation to sink in the Good Samaritan
had never been more terrified something
else began to shift inside the sphere
her a structure was growing out of the
ground up and around him like a cage
within a cage he was trapped and huddled
inside a strange conical structure as
more figures entered the sphere around
him they were just like the first this
horrible horde of desiccated knot people
all with grinning lipless mouths when
they closed in on him the Good Samaritan
had the one consolation that at least it
was over but it wasn't not yet the blind
old man waited in the kitchen for five
hours as unmentionable Horrors unfolded
inside the black sphere the Good
Samaritan was actually lucky all in all
because for some sessions for victims
inside the sphere had lasted as long as
27 hours he screamed the entire time
with a sphere finally demanifesting just
moments after the screaming stopped
remaining was only one of the creatures
but no Good Samaritan just several neat
piles of human organs arranged by organ
type I are you down in there honey the
blind old man asked I've been getting
awfully hungry the creature replied in
perfect English
[Applause]
the creature picked up some of the
discarded organs and took them into the
kitchen where it began cooking them into
a stew for the old man he ate the stew
not long after blissfully ignorant to
its contents and went to sleep whatever
organs from the Good Samaritan weren't
used in the stew were simply thrown into
the fireplace to burn away into ashes
later that night the old man would die
peacefully of a heart attack in his
sleep at age 81. he spent the latter 10
years of his life in service of
scp-957 he'd never even had a wife and
when the monster first invaded his home
he wasn't even blind he'd simply come
home one day to find scp-957 lurking in
his home waiting for him as far as the
SCP Foundation is aware it always
targets people who live alone the man
had tried to resist but the creature was
freakishly strong in spite of its wiry
frame it grabbed him and forced his body
into the dark gaping Chasm of its chest
he was swallowed up into another world
on the other side of the void and
returned four hours later a changed man
his eyes were gone and he now firmly
believed that scp-957 was his beloved if
burnt scarred wife of many years he'd do
anything for her even heading out into
the world and feigning distress to lure
people back into her terrible clutches
that's how the Old Man became
scp-957-1 he wasn't the first and
wouldn't be the last but the old man now
dead scp-957 would Dem manifest and head
off in search of a new victim invading
their home and repeating the cycle once
more somewhere else the somewhat happy
ending is that in one of these cases the
SCP Foundation somehow got wise to the
baiting activities of scp-957 and they
were able to contain the creature giving
it the ketter object class for its
frequent attempts to either get out or
lure in new victims it's never been
actively hostile to Foundation
researchers and guards just a little
obtuse despite the fact that it's
perfectly capable of speaking fluent
English it prefers to speak in an
unknown dead language for somewhat
mysterious reasons very little is known
about the origins or true nature of
scp-957 but our brief glimpse into its
interior life does little to comfort Us
in 2008 the foundation recorded 957
having a conversation with an unseen
individual in its native tongue
Foundation linguistic experts have been
able to partially crack the code on what
was being said that day 957 asked the
Unseen figure how much longer it would
have to stay here the figure told it
that it would need to wait there for a
while and that its disguise was
extremely convincing 957 complained that
being here was boring and tiresome but
the Unseen figure urged 957 to remain
patient it said
foreign
now go check out
scp-1861 the crew of the HMS
wintershimer and scp-5049 the skin
salesman demon Dan's Discount homunculus
Depot for more of the most terrifying
anomalous beings out there